[Music]
mike check mike check what's going on
real you're supposed to say one two oh
you you instructing how it's supposed to
go what's going on y'all major lands
vogus cre hustle and motivate other zc I
see you in there I see you Juan Castilla
what's going on Pixel slapper what's
going on let me know if my levels are
good Master W what's going on you know
what I'm saying all in PE thank you
brother thank you Shan what's going
regulator my mans what's going on man
arcade what's up you got Attic in the
building ad say what's up to the people
who's setting up right now M check my
check one two deala HD grown women
gaming in the building salute boys good
to see you Anthony Vasquez thank you
thank you so yeah we just chilling
getting ready you know what I'm saying
waiting for S and um what you call of
course the legendary the magician
himself Jason Ronald will be joining in
progress you are not Jason Ronald now
live stop it he said Jason Rd
here that's good oh we got window
centrals on Jared Eden what's going on
man salute so I just G to give y'all I I
probably announce this during the show
but just want to give y'all The Rules of
Engagement all right so first of all he
will be joining us in progress you know
what I'm saying once Jason Joy's time is
limited so I cannot cannot answer super
chats during his time so I just want to
give you out of respect for PR and the
whole situation that's what we doing now
after obviously we we'll get stuff in
but we going to try to get as much in as
we can you know what I'm saying and real
quickly sadly the king is not doing well
man I spoke to him last night spoke to
him this morning he's not feeling well
at all so um please send your love to
the king you know what I'm saying you
know he was going to be here for this
one you know what I'm saying so yeah
he's definitely going through it man but
anyway that will be that waiting for the
S to get through we going to do a fresh
on time start and we going to have some
fun in the round man we got the magician
in the building man but yeah salute send
some love to the K man my my dog is not
feeling too well man he's def severely
under the weather so that's what's up
what's up big man Mo thank you brother
thank you it was that thought process
that the one chip challenge made him you
said the one chip the thought of it it's
will be's fault it's will be fa anyway
we going catch with y'all in a bit man
see
[Music]
y'all
I
can't all right and we are live welcome
to the IR Lords podcast and now also
live on Lords of gaming.net episode
number
183 it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
day I'm extremely excited about a very
special guest and we've got the Xbox
series launch imminent the medium delay
Sega financials and an eighth generation
retrospect to discuss so we going to get
right into it
but normally we had a four hement of
gaming but un sadly sadly a brother King
David man he is not feeling well please
real send your love send your tweets man
to the king he is not feeling well trust
me you know he wanted to be here for
this episode you know the king got to be
sick if he can't make this episode yeah
trust me I checked in with him last
night and in the morning he tried to
give it a goal so I had to make the
executive decision for my my brother let
him rest let him get his health back but
the king will be back please send your
love to the king my man you know what
I'm saying so we still got the he said
he
o he said he o on yeah yeah he made OD
on knes man he you know what's crazy I
said I got a new job and people said
King hired me to be his knee
collector yeah salute to the king man he
was intoxicated off the knees man that's
my bro salute I know they weren't my
knees though that's for
sure look at trying to get out of it
know bad I got to kick my man when he's
down kick when he's down and of course
you know we still got the three Horsemen
in gaming those original L of the realm
here at the round table my co-host the
coost my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the H of the young wolf my man
Lord addict how we doing sir doing
pretty good I know I don't have to worry
any about uh uh a king interrupting me
at all today you talking about
interrupting
hit him with the time right quick no
doubt man so what's going on what you
been playing
sir um I've actually just been playing I
played a little bit of the new
Assassin's
Creed I'm not really going to go into
anything that because I don't know what
type of embargos on
embargos well I mean depends if you if
nobody gave it to you you have no
embargo no you still have an embargo you
still have an embargo yeah that's what's
up I I've talked about stuff in the past
that that I got early through other
means and not the developer and I still
got hit with aent oh yeah all right well
that means you're important that's good
what it is is is is everyone's under the
Embargo it's just like they nine times
out of 10 like they won't enforce it on
you because you didn't get like a piece
of paper saying it okay okay ca Kofi
Kofi was talking about um uh Red Dead
Redemption too before it came out yeah
and take two pulled up on him in his DMS
and tell him like we going to need you
to stop they to you know about that
story they're not about not about no he
wasn't even talking about nothing about
the story he was just throwing
screenshots of like the horse and the
title screen and they pulled up on him
you tell me how Kofi ain't said nothing
about games she's got early since then
salute to kof salute to
Kofi like Kofi was like when a company
pulls up on there Ain nothing like a
company pulling up on you live like a
multi-billion dollar company pulling off
on you was like yo stop fam's definely
time on that any other than that that's
been it sir yeah that's what's up what's
up and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the
saamus the Lord of clarity and Patriot
of the iron bank my man Lord Sovereign
how we doing sir I am doing fantastic
today sir I'm so happy man got we got J
Ron the best being in the business
coming through
crazy no no offense ad no offense yeah I
think he got you he got you on theard I
think he got you but yeah man what's
been going on man nothing man no no
gaming no gaming what you know two now
two weeks it's like two months man like
been crazy yeah but and it's it's
looking spooky for the guy man next week
like Amazon has Amazon has yet to charge
me for my console oh man and again I I
know Amazon spooky launch regardless but
that's the one I got through on so that
you know Amazon it is as it and then
when it comes to my Playstation my
PlayStation I had to get you know
through other
means shout out to other means the other
means so we we will see if that arrives
anywhere near uh launch but I I'm not
confident that either so as it stands
I'll be getting my accessories before yo
so wait there's a legit chance you will
not get even console on time nope not so
far unless unless I get notification you
know how they were saying online for
Amazon like uh change the shipping speed
and sometimes that it'll force update it
so I did that uh and it was like nope
nope NOP NOP
no you know be funny if you changed the
speed and it just got put in P by the
back of the
queue completely yeah so the as of right
now the things that are arriving before
uh are my Pulse headset for my uh for my
PlayStation and actually my arctis
headset for the my Xbox those I'll have
both of those in hand those to be ready
for the system that's crazy want get
squirly squirly up in the chat we got
squirly Dan with the $2 Super Chat
driving home with the C10 right now go
get it brother listen I on the C10 man
on the C10 I I held back I'm still
holding my head okay and because the
thing is I'm really holding out hope for
12 bit panels in J so my thing is you
know 12bit color uh 444 chromos sub s
bling so my hope is that we get those in
2021 but if in January after CES we have
no sign of them then I probably jump on
a C10 or or I wait to see what
LG how you gonna
tell plenty of time
yeah we we we we gotta keep it moving oh
we gota keep
it so you holding out no doubt we got to
get you back we got to get you back
gaming though it's been a couple weeks
you yes this is I took I took a couple
of days for this and this is not feeling
this right now and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
unlocked L Cognito spreading that
realness in the ran IOP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear so it's been all Destiny all day
all the time what's up Forte I see you
in there brother we have been prepping
we've been getting ready more stuff I
got to do on that game yeah bro we have
we are in complete prep trying to get
every I got that
catalyst Catalyst get everything ready
because the new exp yes yes yes s we
know look s they're taking stuff out of
the game and we have to do it before it
took out of that's that's hard do you
not realize how horrible that is no very
vocal on how how done that is but at the
end day rather than be like I'm not
doing that you're like no I have to get
it before it's like look look at the end
of the day I'mma do it
like listen I'mma complain while I do oh
yeah yeah definitely listen the the the
the reasoning was given was that
basically they're redoing the engine so
some of the destinations are going into
this cont content Vault and then um from
there they'll be rebr back again I
understand for the destiny hating
contingent they might not like it but um
what I would say is yeah we have you
have to get some of these uh really
ideal weapons before they get some of
them get vaulted the planets get vaulted
so I just working on that so that we
could have the ideal setup for the world
first raid cuz some of these weapons are
extremely powerful
super that super chat's about you
Stitch yeah Stitch Super Chat assab
Amazon does not charge you until the day
before it ships if you see the estimated
delivery for Tuesday you're good no I
have no estimated delivery it's telling
me yeah we will tell you when it's
shipping out that's what it tells me
shout out to Forte he's got 63 bodies on
every guard that's dizzy AR remove
content I got yeah cuz I AR no way a
playing AR let me stop let me stop let
me stop decision we ever made was giving
these people the time oh yeah now look
at NE look at his hating division so
soon as Destiny starts getting talked
about look at
them now they now they would have Flex
the time of you guys are just mad
because there's never nothing to do on
the division so we're never talking
exactly you guys think that all that
stuff that's getting vaulted most of it
comes back most of it yeah they're going
to repackage it and sell it to us again
there's a there's also a big rumor in
reference to
what the new IP actually is and they may
there's a rumor that they may be going
full wow full wow really factions light
darkg like full on and and in order to
do that that may be again just like a
twoe again rumors but some these things
you have to rebuild the game at that
point so that's it but also real quick
special announcement if I know you get
the Super Chat is that um yo this um
what you call something that again for
more Destiny talk Philly is U last word
was no last word Friday huge guest
Cognito do a double duty today huge
guest tonight we got the legendary
mercules from Bungie and Reddit Fame
check it out it'll be a super late night
Edition because it's schedule in so
it'll be 9:00 P p.m. Eastern check that
out with my brother iones that will be a
big one as well so check that out s go
get the Super Chat I'm feeling that name
though mercules
mercules what's up all right we got
Smitty Smith with the $5 Super Chat what
kind of world we live in when Lord s
might not get his consoles as hard as he
works yeah thank you I appreciate that I
think it's time to activate hash other
means listen other means usually
work except for console launches like
the my my other means for my PlayStation
happened right at right right when
pre-orders went up so I had wiggle room
at this point there's no wiggle room bro
if you if you don't have that you know
that back door like you ain't getting it
you ain't getting it is it is what it
is the pre-order is in right so it's a
matter when it comes but and I got it in
the funny thing is with Amazon you
remember that Amazon everybody thought
the site was frozen and what it was is
it didn't even go live on time it went
live almost an hour later so um we had
KATU doing it for me and KATU it was
like an hour later when he got through
so I'm like so basically I got in right
in the beginning of it then so I'm
thinking I was good and
apparent bro that's SS we got a super
chat or we good we got yeah we got Neil
mental with the $5 Super Chat sorry I
don't take the division hate from
lowlevel division players that hold on
hold on hold
on De mental brother you cannot talk
with your game does not exist when your
online Play account does not
exist man I'm G need I'm gonna need the
mods to keep that man in check for the
rest of the
podcast somebody get
Neil on
PA you know what I'm saying but it's all
jokes man but look real quickly
obviously you know big guest obviously
Lord Jason will be joining us in
progress so we got to establish some
Rules of Engagement when he comes in you
know what I mean so obviously time is
limited and we know we normally get all
your super chats but during his segment
we have to focus on Lord Jason so I just
want to be very clear and transparent
about that because I know guys like yo
you need get my Super Chat the Lord's
always what's up and you know we always
do but we have to respect PR we have to
respect the Rules of Engagement so when
he joins we're just going to jump Jump
Right In you know what I'm saying and
set them up right so that's what I want
it is let's get these up oh J
yes let me I'm for a second J du is a
shill with a $5 Super Chat are we going
to talk about the PS super duper oer
looper fast SD I mean it's so fast that
it's letting Xbox load games faster Mar
versus lock uh JW is a chill I don't
know if you've heard my friend yes but
you were the winner of the ILP
PlayStation 5 giveaway
congratulations and you know what's
funny like I was sitting there I was
talking to Lura cognito you haven't been
able to get back to us so I was like yo
I was like that dude is always in our
chat I feel so bad if we have to get
some else it was looking Spooky For You
JBS and Sh were like yo yeah if we don't
hear from you we may have to roll this
we yeah we were about to pull that rug
out from under you my brother so uh
thank goodness you're in the chat today
I know that you you pride
yourself know you really won you really
bro you won the play you won you won the
the the uh who did that for you bad mod
is the one that won the Xbox exactly
exactly so uh Jay dub get at me in my
DMs I know you proud yourself on being
mysterious but if you want this Council
I'm gonna need that
government factual come up off that fact
so come up off that so we G need to know
who you are don't worry I will not
snitch you out to the world um but as we
said last week and you did not hear we
do not as of now have these console so
if you have a pre-order elsewhere do not
cancel that pre-order because you will
be disappointed on launch day but you
get your console when we get it you will
get it abolutely um so let me read these
other super chats congratulations once
again we have elemental PO with the $15
Super Chat Series S finally showing a
ray tracing on budget yes we yes yes
Watch Dogs looking crazy PS5 SS the
expansion a no show at launch sing along
nights like this I wish rain drops
nights like
this that heartbeat flavor that
heartbeats yeah ni Smith $2 Super Chat
Beyond light inbound Warlock baby
warlock stand up you already know the F
that's not even English to me I don't
know
what then we have big cloud gaming with
the $5 Super Chat congrats on the
interview guys this show is always five
appreciate you big cloud PlayStation NA
stand up respect the love man respect
the love uh one other thing I wanted to
say before Jason comes on um guys go out
there and show your love to Nintendo
Guru
Nintendo uh has not been well um there's
I guess a GoFundMe out there right now I
don't have the link uh available I don't
know if you can find it Cog to put that
in chat um Guru is one of the nicest
people in in this entire Community go
out show him love uh he's not doing well
right now so we need to get behind get
behind him also before you get the next
chat I want to shout out the wise old
Gable who's in here he just went through
a serious medical procedure yeah he was
very concerned himself and he got
through he's on the other side good to
see you in the chat brother you know
what I'm saying good to to see in the
chat I I see you doing he said even he
said hey I got my new TCL EKG got my hot
nurse even the ICU can't keep me away
today let's go fam bro salute to him man
because again he's even able CU he was
like look not even a console launch he
gonna miss they're GNA able to put the
series X and PS5 in his hospital room so
salute to him man that's good to see you
brother good to see you let's get you
see CH yeah fantastic that we have Dan
the Man Cunningham with the $5 Super
Chat greetings Lords hope you all are
well thank you for all you do for Super
Chat and prep of Lord cogo's great Mass
Effect listen let me get it right quick
let me get it right quick we still got
time we still got time for for Jason to
show listen y'all we're gonna do a
podcast right before the trilogy it's
going to be the Mass Effect one Lords
versus the Mass Effect two Lords the
great debate a lot of people on the
wrong side of History picking Mass
Effect one but I'mma let y'all slide y g
to make your heretic argument I don't
know what talking about listen Mass
Effect one is the greatest just for one
reason alone only one reason why is the
greatest why is it the greatest I don't
know you tell me oh because the the the
boss's name is
Sovereign my name you know you know
what's funny the last boss to XCOM to uh
to this new XCOM game came out the
spinoff the last boss to that was s was
s to yeah he got he got bias but it's
listen at the end of the day fun
argument fun argument great J shout out
to Sarah and I a good but we already
know the suicide mission and the
mechanic we going to get into that but
yo salute to you Dan mam we going to set
it up look right now look like the panel
going to be whole glore it's going to be
Porche power my man anley Bill
stairwells on Mass Effect one side then
I got T Travis I got Sam tobert I got
slowmo so I got my I got my goons with
me they got their Mass Effect one goons
it's G to be a good show so before the I
would argue I would argue that Mass
Effect one Mass Effect
2 was uh careful action gamified so much
that you could argue that one is an RPG
and one isn't really an RPG I know where
y going with that I know where y i I got
my I a going to give you my balls yet
argued I going give you my bars yet but
I I know where yall going with that pure
RPG but we going to talk about that moo
transversal and other terrible parts of
the game that people tend to
forget I mean
listen you already know it's
over planet planet mining was a whole
Rabbit Hole unto
itself you can ask Cognito I've actually
been talking because I never really got
into the mass effects and uh I was going
to try them out and then when this was
announced I was like I might as well
just wait till spring at this point and
just for the record adct just so you
know the reason why the trilogy was held
up because of all the issues with part
one and they trying to remaster so I
just want to make it clear the reason
why you're not able to experience this
greatness is because of Mass Effect one
continue
wow for the little little bit I played
at the first I actually really we need
we need a go post moving
emo you guys know I don't know if you
know this uh cogn you can put polls in
the chat now oh that's I didn't even
know that I didn't even know that we got
definitely got let's get these super
chats y let's get super CH we got punkin
is with the $5 Super Chat I haven't seen
you in a while brother been busy over
the last year but still support you
great gaming dudes awesome giveaway
thank you punkish good to see you in the
good to see you brother I hav see that's
my destiny bro you know what say we got
Smith for the $5 Super Chat Wise Old
gamer Nintendo Guru and Lord King David
we are with you the book of Acts that's
scripture baby that's for sure though
you so we caught up then we have stits
with the $2 Super Chat let's be honest
can't have two without one and me one
fire yeah baby here we go yeah uh so let
let me say something yeah Jason we'll be
joining later probably within like 10 to
15 minutes uh L L Caro said earlier we
not we will not be engaging in the chat
during the time that uh he's here we
only have him for 30 minutes and we
definitely want to do as much with that
time as we possibly can so any super
chats that come in will read after he
has left apologies in advance apologies
in advance so don't come at the L I
didn't read my y' got Hollywood because
did no we gotta respect the legend his
time it it it doesn't matter if it
pushes our podcast in the three and a
half hours we always read you guys this
Super Chat exactly you already know what
it is man but yeah man so also too I
know saw we'll have some business to
attend to afterwards right we got some
things we got to take care of you know
what I'm saying punk dis what's going on
you know oh they starting the candy war
in there I can't with you man I can't
with the marsall I do it too much I
doing too Bill St turned on me
completely by the way shout out to L
Bill still yeah CA he's like you like
Milky Way he said we bonded over go g
said ask Ronald how uh how much air
flops it took
to you get your questions don't doubt oh
Smitty oh Smitty Smith let me read
this chat Mass Effect one goat status
that is my Square thank you hold hold up
okay okay okay I don't know nothing
about it but let's settle this right now
put in the chat you like the first one
better put in the chat if you like the
second one better put in the chat if you
like the third one
better no one two three or four like put
say put in the chat for which one you
like the most and if you like the drumer
for some reason put four TR the turbo TV
Mass the goat you know Mass Effect two
is the go one one for the first two for
the second three for the third and four
for and and we have e fan
76 oh Mass Effect one created the magic
feeling I got that continue to two so I
don't know Cog Mass Effect is the best
SciFi tril
ever it's bad ones in there I surprised
but two is coming up strong now but yeah
it's actually we got we got Hans
Olo you know what you know what
considering you guys somebody said four
don't even start with Andromeda that is
even who is that Jesus but a cat you're
out of here yo there's a lot of people
that likes one yeah a lot I'm surprised
with this a lot of people like one I am
very surprised listen one for its time
you understand like remember like we
hadn't experienced anything like that so
everybody was losing in mind over one
and then it got refined into but then
some people did I didn't mind the fact
that they sort of removed some of the
some of the granular RPG elements
because the thing is it it appealed to
more people at that point right not
about that deep RPGs they just not like
one is the only one I played but by the
time I got to it it was so outdated like
I didn't mind the the game play it's
just like the actual gamep play was
outdated like like you know with um with
some life uh easy what's what's what's
word they they say when you want
something that's easier well we'll get
to that in one second what's the term
they say when you make something easier
on like the UI moves like Life Is Life
Changes yeah oh what quality of life
quality of life Improvement quality of
life improvements yeah that's I feel
like the first one needs that more than
anything else and that's the thing
though that'll be funny though that if
if they go it back into one and they
eliminate all that RPG granular stuff
and
it yeah I mean then it could shine but
at in its original for people have
revisioned this history to go back
exactly we we are being prisoners of the
moment cuz when you was in them
elevators y'all remember what it was
y'all was in that moo and the joint
wasn't traversing and how awful that I I
know I know a lot of you guys love the
idea of the exploration the Star Trek fi
it gave that yes the RPG mechanics I get
it I get it it was empty though it was
yes don't forget the words don't forget
the words but yo we got these crazy
super chats we got to take care of yeah
we got shroom Kingdom with the $50 Super
Chat thank you so much appreciate it
y'all done goofed I was looking forward
to winning the PS5 with card reader
thank you guys for all the hours of
entertainment Mass Effect one and two
are on different levels but one set it
all too many ones in here y'all I don't
know what's going on I don't know what's
going
on you you looking like that looking
like the our our
president stop
the let me stop I don't do politics in
the real but I had to I had to do that
one we got we got 460 people in the chat
I want to thank all of you coming out
definitely hit that like button if you
guys don't mind let's get let's get that
over 200 before Lord yeah comes in else
we got
smith2 super chat Rex Garris t game set
match hold on sh all first off she to
say yes but but you know what y' ain't
got thing baby y' ain't got thing thing
was to go but um anyway let's get shade
tombling let me get that five pound
where is my PS5 and Xbox you promise I'd
win congrats to the winners K here Lord
kog whated he said the book you can't
hear me oh man what else you got listen
oh yeah uh Lord Shane I don't know the
bag wasn't dropped off the iron bank
does not recall the bag being dropped
off the same thing I told Forte I'm like
look you you you'll check bounce like I
don't know what to tell
you right there we have a big shout out
to the wise old gamer upgrading his
membership to Lord gold thank you my
brother put the horns in the chat y' man
put the horns in the chat man hold on
let me get jbo money he's so messy jbo
money $2 Super Chat y'all see the 49ers
game on Thursday call yes I saw it's
funny how you only hit me up off of
losses I find that very interesting but
I got my Reddit Gold on I'm still
repping look man decimated season what
we going to do man shout out to Brandon
Tyro shout out to my D shout out to
redit gold nation but it ain't happening
this year man we might have a Jimmy G
problem but we'll anyway what else we
got oh before that we actually had
masshole 1977 with the $2 Super Chat
morning Lords waiting on a ship date for
my ex yes sir we are in the same boat
and apparently a lot of people in the
chat are in the same boat as well they
haven't got yet so after J Mo we got
Lucius Augustus with a $ five Super Chat
that is a very
serious very that's that person that
they be talking about like RPGs that I'm
just like I don't know if I want to
fight that dude spicus man that's like
the last boss
Lu right right before you get to
batiatus that's that dude that you cut
that cut your arm off at the beginning
of the game and you have to structure
the Revenge so we got Luc August with
the $5 Super Chat I was kick flipping
the moo I don't know what y'all talking
about yeah you had to kick flick the
make you get stuck all the damn time
then we have oh we have Stitch once
again hold on yeah we have Stitch once
again with the $5 Super Chat I played
Mass Effect when I was 16 I'm 35 now and
still remember that game don't remember
two or three as well
oh
spooky it looks like they're turning you
into the minority I don't know what's
going on these dudes got rici this
history that's all right there we got
kiss move with the $5 Super Chat last
IOP without a nextg console congrats on
the Jr interview thank you Lord Smo okay
Smo I got you we had talk I got
you we actually combined your stuff with
mine see you're good oh great then we
have Eric Franklin with the $10 Super
Chat huge fan of you guys and excited to
hear Jason speak salute yeah I remember
you on Twitter brother thank you for
that man thank you for the con words
we're gonna have a fun show he'll be in
here shortly definitely exactly exactly
then we have pixel bit G with the $5
Super Chat Spider-Man Miles Morales is
native 4K with rate tracing on PS5 I
don't think that is true impressed and
Series S can actually do raate tracing
wow big up to the panel launch week
let's go I'm I don't know it's native 4K
with rate tracing on I'm not sure I'm
not sure maybe maybe I'm I'm thinking
about frame rate I know the frame rate
is definitely you
guys did you guys see those screenshots
of Watch Dogs on the Xbox series X of R
Racing that stuff crazy like I'm not a
technical person but I was like those
Reflections ref look really yeah I
really like looking at the miles footage
what not like I honestly I think I'm
gonna play it at 30 because I really
want to see that's this is the debate
right it's the debate and it honestly
seeing it I'm 60 all the way I'm done
with this 30 y the r tracing though R
tracing for the bushes if it it
me this the r tracing is very impressive
but being able to walk without a without
any type of pause is more impressive
okay we got pixel bit again with the 22
Super Chat confirmed on Twitter by
digital Foundry shocked it is what it is
then we have code with the $10 oh man
the legend don't y'all hate trolling on
Twitter can't stand don't you start
don't you start you be the main Fire
Starter you tri shout to C is in a
matter of weeks Cod has put himself in a
position yes it it and I I commend you
brother because I would not want that
smoke coming at me if you're still in
the chat kid if you're still in the
catch put in the chat who won that poll
that you made oh that was funny but yo
shout out to co right here I want to
shout out rapping those guys the guys
had red gaming Tech great technical
interview shout out to slow shout out to
gu it was really I got a chance to
listen to it you know what I'm saying
you was in your back I I like Optimus
code on podcast I don't know about the
other dude who's that dude on Twitter
the Twitter guy I don't know him but
code on on a podcast that's my guy
salute Co man good to see you up here
brother he said I want that troll P yo
he's funny he messy he messy salute so
before we actually get into I we I know
we're doing patreon afterwards but
something I forgot last week so shout
out to our boy talk about that slow SSD
hold let me do key will 26 if you guys
recall I had said key will was going to
donate uh an additional three months of
Game Pass ultimate to the winner of the
Xbox series X so uh shout out to uh what
is it big bad Mo Big B bigad Mo yeah big
bad Mo um and shout out to key will 26 I
will be giving you an extra three months
of Game Pass ultimate courtesy of key
will so that's arrive the legend has
entered can you hear us Lord Jason can
you hear us your levels are good I can
hear you guys how you guys doing this
morning how are you much better now man
so we gonna get right into it we know
your time is limited Jason is so extra
with that beard I gotta do
this I can't even the second one in the
group man listen man we GNA hit the
ground roller Lord Jason is here so you
know we got to enter him into the realm
correctly so let's start it I want to
introduce a lord who's multiac and
highly illustrious career in the games
industry is truly remarkable under the
Xbox platform whether it be his Forward
Thinking approach when it comes to
console design or tremendous technical
acen when discussing it his passion for
gaming always
resonates introducing the director of
program management for team Xbox and
leader in development of the Xbox series
X and Series S
consoles the wizard of project Scarlet
most majestic beard in the game and come
November 10th will be responsible for
all Gamers to power their
dreams live from Redmond and kind enough
to make his debut into the realm of the
Lords my man Lord Jason Ronald how you
doing sir I'm very well how you guys
doing man really appreciate being here
dude absolute pleasure you are Lord at
what you do man only right we show you
the proper respect here at the round
table so if if you don't mind we going
to Jump Right In brother if you don't
mind let's jump
in so look man a lot going on right now
so for me I want to set it off um you
know Lord Jason I'm coming from PC let's
past generation most of the time playing
my favorite game Destiny 2 right so the
series X really excites me because it's
far superior to my current CPU and GPU
setup right but one of the key features
I've been preaching specifically is that
the mvme the quick resume low times now
I know you can't speak on the
competition but early reports from media
Outlets have showed the series X to be
outperforming the PS5 SSD and multiple
back compact games as well as um
resuming from a standby State and um
also the uh multi-game quick them not
having the multi-game quick resum
feature so I know optimization patches
they're not in for all the Next
Generation games but can you explain how
Xbox velocity architecture is capable of
this or if it's even being taken
advantage of by when in theory the raw
SSD was supposed to be a clear Advantage
by your
competitor sure so I would say at this
early stage you know people are still
learning how to take full advantage of
the Velocity architecture you know you
talk about something like quick resum as
a great example that's something that as
we started putting the hardware together
and we started getting the operating
system up and running we recognized
there was unique opportunities to go
even further beyond what the raw
Hardware specifications could and then
depending on the game that you're
actually playing some games are just
really benefiting from the raw Hardware
advantages that we have but as we expect
to go you know year two year three year
four you're really going to see changes
in how games are built how they're
designed to really take full advantage
of it and I think that's as a system
designer that's what's really exciting
is when you launch a new platform you're
really setting the technical direction
for the next seven to 10 years of game
development so if you think about the
games that you're going to experience on
day one we're super excited by what
developers are already able to do with
it but it's going to be even more
exciting with what they're going to be
able to do later on in the generation
absolutely very very impressive level
we're seeing and definitely you know
it's it's impressive stuff man
impressive stuff so we got to jump right
into addict's question which is kind of
the second part it's a two-part and uh
mostly with Xbox series s and um the the
first part of it was what was it like to
just work on like this super secret
simultaneous project right that's going
on that you know most of the you know
media in the world does not think it's
existing but you know it existed so
that's part one right and then part two
with the Xbox series s is um one thing
we're seeing from you know the early
install sizes of Xbox series s games
being much smaller in comparison to
series X so we seen it with see thieves
dirt five and um I believe um forgot
what the third game is but it's about
three games I've seen so far but like
how will storing a game on the storage
expansion card of the series X be
impacted when you place that same card
in the series s given that there is a
size
difference yeah so I mean to your first
question you know it's always fun to be
working on all kinds of things here and
you know obviously we listen to the
community what we watch what's being
chatted about uh and sometimes the
community spot on with what we're
working on and sometimes it's they're
wildly off so your point uh it's kind of
fun to kind of watch the speculation out
there but honestly for us it's just
really exciting to actually just share
what we really are working on and share
kind of all the details behind it so you
know that's one of the fun parts of
being on the inside of the industry is
you know what the truth is you know what
the internet discussion is and just
discovering where that difference
is you must you must chuckle sometimes
about that I know some times and then
there's also times where it's like wow
how did they figured this
out we must have a leak
somewhere side we're all looking around
like all right wait's doing what I know
so it's reference to the the second part
as far as the SSD the expansion slot
with the going from a series X to a
series s where the the hard drive space
is a little bigger on the game how's
that impacted on the S is there any
change or yeah there's really no change
you can take the exact same storage
expansion card pull it out of your
series X and plug it into a series s and
just be able to boot the games directly
from there if you downloaded the game
originally on the series s and the
developers done the work to say for
example you don't need the 4K assets on
the series s when you plug that into the
series X you'll be prompted to download
those assets if you want to go ahead and
use them so we really focus on making it
as easy as possible you know the vast
majority of people will likely only own
One console so it really comes down to
you know if you're on a series s we want
to be as respectful as we can with your
available storage we want to deliver
that same great Next Generation gaming
experience but you know for me
personally at home I switch between both
consoles all the time and I just pull
the storage expansion card out plug it
into the other one and just pick up and
play from there that is pretty
impressive especially considering the
like I said not having to deal with the
4K assets and being able to make the
game smaller on the S in respect to the
hard drive situation there a digital
platform pretty pretty impressive so I
want to let s jump off I know he's got
some questions I think in reference to
machine
learning yes so uh so Jason uh actually
in in regards to what you were saying
before about how you're excited about
how the developers are going to be using
the machine you know two years down the
line and really being able to use all
the all the new sort of bells and
whistles in the series X and the series
s so my big question is about machine
learning um because uh every console
generation you sort of hear about like
this the sauce right the this this magic
thing that you've never seen before and
you're like how does that even work and
when I heard about machine learning and
what it was capable of doing with lower
resol games running at lower resolutions
it sort of it seemed like magical to me
so so my question is to what extent do
you expect these games uh a as as the
generation moves on these games
utilizing machine learning and uh if I
could give you a potential scenario and
see if that's something that we can
feasibly s sort of be expecting um can
we at some point see a game running
internally at 720p or 1080p be upres
through machine learning to to 4K in a
way that is kind of IND discernible from
from um from native 4K and if that is
the case then where does all that
performance overhead go can we feasibly
see that that same game running at at UH
60 frames per second and maybe like
something that's comparable to to ultra
ultra settings on a PC
yeah I mean to be honest like
theoretically yes um you know I think
one of the things that's interesting for
us is there's certain things that we do
at the platform level that we can do to
make all games better so a great example
of this is like Auto HDR there's no work
that a developer actually has to go do
we can uh take advantage of that at the
platform level another good example is
like variable refresh rate we do that at
the platform level so that the developer
doesn't actually have to code against
that so we make it easier for them but
at the same time when it comes to other
features like rate tracing or machine
learning we also provide direct access
to that Hardware to the developers as
well so they can actually choose to use
those capabilities in different ways so
you're talking about like super sampling
there's certain things that we would be
able to do at the platform level but
then a developer could also choose to
use the machine learning for things like
better AI better animations so this is
kind of all the things that we work on
very closely with the developers all
across the industry we try make it as
easy as possible for them but also give
them the flexibility to go even further
than what we can do at the platform
level awesome yeah pretty awesome so I
want to shout out Lord King sadly he's
sick he really was trying to be here he
was definitely sick to to miss the
legendary you know saying Jason so shout
out to the king man but this was his
question in reference to he says so what
was the bigger priority in as far as the
as far as the design of the of of the
console was it the consistent power and
efficiency of the box or the overall
size in regards to air flow and noise
reduction definitely performance uh the
form really follows the function of the
console you know when we first started
we really set very audacious uh you know
performance targets we knew we wanted to
Target 12 Tera flops we knew we wanted
to really step up the CPU performance we
knew that we needed to go to SSD level
performance and that's what led to the
Xbox velocity architecture so as we
designed the system we really made it a
b big challenge for the mechanical
engineering team and the thermal team
and the industrial design team to figure
out how can we deliver all of this
performance deliver all of this power in
the smallest form factor possible and
huge credit to the mechanical
engineering and the industrial design
team to come up with the design and the
architecture that they put together uh
because we're super proud of how small
the form factor is and then you look at
something like the Xbox series s it is
literally when you actually see it in
person it is so small um and it's really
incredible work by the teams yeah it it
it truly is I mean like I said just
seeing the tear downs and you guys you
know in the studios I believe with
digital Foundry and and just the form
factor really impressed me you know how
you guys are able to get that Tech in
and then also as far as ventilation and
Cooling and stuff like that very very
impressive man you guys are Wizards also
want to jump in as far as um rdna2 so
rna2 you know we know we know the recent
announcement with you guys AMD but I
want to know like the importance of the
feature set and why was waiting for the
full feature set from AMD so important
to the team and the development of the
console like I mentioned earlier you
know when you design a hardware platform
like this you're really setting the
direction for the next seven to 10 years
so it's critically important to us that
we have all of these capabilities even
if say on day one uh not all developers
take advantage of them or we haven't
provided all the the various
capabilities it's really with an towards
where do we see the future of gaming
going right and the other thing for us
is a lot of the benefits of rdna to
Beyond you know capabilities like raid
tracing and whatnot it's really about
the efficiency and how developers can be
more efficient and how they use the
hardware to deliver experiences beyond
the actual raw hardware specs themselves
right you know things like uh variable
rate shading that allows developers to
really put the GPU performance in the
areas of the scene that really matter
and then you know not wasting those
Cycles in areas where you're not going
to see the difference where it's say
Shadows or there's various blur effects
you look at something like sampler
feedback sampler feedback allows us to
go even beyond the memory performance
and the io performance to deliver those
transformative experiences so we
partnered really closely with AMD to
really make sure that this uh these
consoles can deliver above and beyond
the raw specifications wow it's pretty
pretty impressive stuff man like I said
you heard some the announcement and like
I said hearing these features you know
and and and knowing that the like that
full set is going to be there is is very
impressive and and and cool you know as
far as the development knowing that
you're going to get the most out of it
um another question we had as far as um
the back compa and 30 frames per second
games now we've seen from how explain me
if I'm wrong right from my understanding
if the
developer has a frame rate unlocked
right in the game like for example like
a Witcher 3 that when you know the the
brute force of the series X and the S
can expand those frame rates out but
then we're seeing situations which
surprised me which was when you guys
showed off I believe Xbox wire The
Fallout 4 and from my understanding that
was a locked frame rate game that is now
being P boosted past that that that that
that threshold so the question is will
we see any more of that is that
something that's something that you guys
have to work in conjunction with the
developer is this another brute force
tactic like how is that possible like I
was really Amazed by how you guys got
Fallout 4 to do that sure so you know
this is the one area that I will give
the team credit of they truly are
magicians you know our back andat team
really like it's beyond just getting the
games to play we want the games to play
better than you've ever seen them before
so they really look at you know with all
this extra Headroom that we have on
these next Generation systems this is
well beyond the power that the games
were originally designed for so to your
point if a title uses things like
Dynamic resolution scaling or they have
unlocked frame rates we're going to run
them with the full performance of these
nextg systems so they're just going to
run better than you've ever seen them
before but if you look at what we did
with the Xbox One X as an example taking
an original Xbox game that was
originally designed for 480p and
actually getting it to run natively at
4K that was through a lot of super
low-level work that the team did and the
game doesn't actually know that it's
doing it and we're doing the same thing
with some of these double frame rate
scenarios where we're kind of Faking the
title out to get it to run faster than
it was originally designed to some of
the challenges with these techniques
though is it won't work for all games
right you know we've had some games
where we've actually tested uh some of
these techniques out the game itself
runs at the higher frame rate but say
the crowds animate twice as fast okay so
you know you we would never ship a game
that way but it's how the game was
originally designed and how the internal
timings within the title works but we're
actively working across a whole series
of titles right now and we'll have more
to share about uh how we do it as well
as what games we'll be able to support
it currently post launch so so for those
games that are that are blocked off and
don't actually can't don't respond to
the brute force of the machine if the
developer wanted to could they go back
in there and do that work to open up
those frame rates and allow that to
happen absolutely you know they can they
a developer could choose to release an
update to the title that either unlocks
the frame rate or possibly add a
performance or a quality mode that's
completely within the control of the
developer and then in many ways that's
kind of the easiest way to take
advantage of the power of these consoles
but they also have to make sure it
continues to work as they expect on last
generation consoles as well so it's
ultimately a developer Choice that's
pretty that's pretty awesome man sh
shout out to speaking to Bungie and
getting them to get my game on December
8th to do what it needs to
do let me ask Lord Jason something real
quick Jason you know I'm a huge fan of a
lot of older games
I'm just curious from your perspective
of a game that was being worked on that
you know it could be anything from The
Witcher that you was excited to play on
you know the Xbox series X was there any
like particular game that you yourself
was excited
about you know to be honest it's just
really amazing to play any game from the
back catalog and see how different and
how much better it plays on this nextg
system you know like there's games that
I've played earlier this year on the
Xbox series X and I hadn't played the
the game in like six or seven years
booted the game up my game save
instantly came down so I'm transported
to exactly where I was six or seven
years ago and I forgot that the game
even had load screens because playing on
the series X I never actually see the
load screens so I went back and played
on my 1X and I was like oh my gosh I
forgot that this
game you know there's other games like
Geometry Wars is one that I always talk
about the first time I played Geometry
Wars with auto HDR like that game was
just stunning you know and it it's like
in many ways it's the way I mentally
remember it but then you go play it
without Auto HDR and you you you don't
realize how transformative that is and
then you know the other thing too is
just there's a whole series of games
that I think we all know and love that
occasionally they'll drop frames or
maybe they'll be in a a section of the
game where it's like oh yeah we always
saw a Dro frames here and now to just
see them run buttery smooth uh like
that's how I remember these games and
that's how I want to play these games so
I mean to be honest like I probably
played on on the order of you know 40 to
50 games this year on the series X wow
um it's just like it's just so awesome
that my entire catalog moves forward
with me that's pretty awesome yeah guys
uh I'm a huge fan of Final Fantasy and I
completely dropped 13 never played
it you cut out backwards when I saw the
backwards compatibility I was like that
looking nice I can't ble Jason his team
got me PL try into this game again abely
so your point uh Final Fantasy is one of
my favorite franchises of all time I
played I've played every Final Fantasy
on the series X and I can confirm they
all run and play better than you've ever
seen them oh man I can't wait man I got
I got two more questions for you before
you just got my approval man he got the
co he got he let he say Final Fantasy
he's got the coside you know what saying
so real quick um two things that excite
me really excite me what you guys are
doing doing the the the pushing for 120
frame rate modes Herz frame rate modes
and then also rate tracing right so the
thing I I'm really excited about is
again coming from the PC mostly on L
generation to see these kind of modes in
the console setting you know giving the
developers that flexibility but also
with the rate tracing will there be a
situation because from my understanding
it's very performance intensive so will
there be a situation where you know you
guys give developers the option or is
this going to be purely develop a base
to say okay rate tracing on like at 30
frames or have modes where rate tracing
can be disabled if people want the
prioritize the frame rates in that
case yeah this is totally up to the
developer you know we don't dictate
resolution or frame rates or what
features they need to you know adopt it
really comes down to the developer knows
their IP their franchise their game
world and their player base better than
anybody else so it's really up to them
on how do I take full advantage of this
you know if you think about like a
fighting game or a competitive shooter
you know to your point in the PC space
we know frame rates matter so that's why
we added those capabilities and even
Beyond just the raw frame rates we
optimize input latency end to endend
through the entire uh pipeline so that
you get that most responsive gaming
experience if that's critical for your
game experience and then there's going
to be other games where it's going to be
massive large open worlds these
universes that you want to be in and it
really comes down to you know maybe
visual quality is more important or
things like rate tracing so for us it's
really about providing a set of tools
and a canvas to the developer and then
really letting them deliver on that
Creative Vision that is really important
for their player base absolutely one
last question before I pass it back off
um XBox in reference to your Xbox
controllers and you know we know the new
controllers obviously you have that
share button and then also the latency
has been improved right tremendously so
the question
if I bring this OG bad boy into the
frame will I be getting some type of
firmware update to actually kind of even
maybe get closer to what the newer
controller from a latency standpoint
especially with things like xcloud and
all these other things going on like
will that be in play from a firmware
perspective yeah so all your existing
controllers move forward with you and
they're available on day one the new
Xbox controller has DLI or dynamic
latency input that really optimizes that
and then we're planning on bringing
Dynamic latency input back to the
existing Xbox One controllers in a
firmware update in 2021 so unfortunately
we weren't able to land it for day one
uh but we are going to bring that back
because to your point you know the Elite
Series 2 is one of my favorite
controllers I want that exact same
experience so we're g to bring it back
in 2021 now now quick question now this
I may be asking a lot but I have to ask
it in reference to the elite to was the
cool thing about the new one is the
share button itself so I know in with
the Elite 2 that button is kind of a
toggle between modes is there any way
that could be changed to a share button
itself like it mimic the other
controller no just that that's just the
functionality of the
controller yeah but you can also map any
button to any function so if you wanted
to you could map the share functionality
to like a back paddle or one of the
buttons so once again it's totally in
your control as a player to customize
that experience uh but you can
absolutely map the sharing functionality
do another button on the controller that
is awesome s I'm going give you one more
made his we you made my week I was like
cuz I need my I need to take my
screenshots I need to I love the new
aspect of it because it reminds me of
the switch and how cool it is just the
holding down for a minute and it's so
the it's just the EAS of views but S I
want to give you another question I know
I've been going in um I we just talked
so much about like the technical
breakdown of the console like you know
Tuesday can't get here soon enough right
but I Jason as somebody who works on
Tech I know that you guys are always
looking forward right so regardless of
the fact that you still have a couple of
days to launch and then we have this
entire generation to think about is
there anything Tech wise on the horizon
that excites you that that for the
future in a way that that we haven't
even talked about yet like things that
that you you can see being sort of
integrated even into this console
generation even moving beyond
that yeah I mean you mentioned uh super
sampling and machine learning there's a
lot of opportunity here and I think
we're at the just very early stages of
that clearly we believe in believe in it
enough to have Hardware acceleration for
it in the hardware but it's really about
how do we take full advantage of that
and then I think the other thing too is
you know we're very gamer Centric as
opposed to device Centric so you
mentioned rdna2 earlier all those same
capabilities that exist on series X and
Series S will exist on the PC as well
you talk about things like project
xcloud as an example how is the
developer can I build a game for these
nextg consoles and take full advantage
of those same capabilities in the cloud
and then for you as a player it's just
really about how can you best experience
your games on any device whether that's
if you're a primarily console player if
you're a PC player or if you may never
buy a PC or a console you want still
want access to those games on your
mobile device so I think for me that's
really the exciting thing is how do we
take this really uh immersive content
and deliver it to players in all new
ways that we've never been able to do
before that's fantastic absolutely to
that point uh about the the the cloud
stuff so when the beginning of the Xbox
one generation they they obviously they
talked about how you could integrate
Cloud into like helping local machines
perform better and that sort of gotten
away from that is that something that
that that really can be utilized in this
upcoming generation or is this is that
an idea that sort of didn't necessarily
pan out in terms of how it works in
practice I I think we're really early in
the cloud you know obviously it's super
awesome to be able to play my games on
my mobile device and stuff like that
you've seen some some titles try
different things like running physics in
the cloud or some level of like
cloud-based rendering combined with
local rendering so I think that's going
to be an area that's just going to be
full of innovation over the next five to
seven years really figuring out the most
effective ways to Leverage The Cloud to
once again go beyond whatever the raw
capabilities of the client device are
absolutely yeah def excites me I'm sorry
I'm give it right to you ad just because
I know we've had uh Bill Stillwell on
before and he was like I said one of the
Pioneers when in terms of backup pack
and and Cloud it's just so impressive to
see what Azure is able to do and
hopefully those server blades get
updated to the uh series X one as
eventually as it come but I'm G let you
go add I just want to get that off so
I'm I'm I'm the one that asks you all
the the the silly stuff because they ask
you the serious stuff I'm not a tech
person I don't ask you stuff I could
never relate to but I want to know Jason
what is your most anticipated game for
Next Generation we going
there uh I know about some games that
nobody else knows
right well obviously we're not referring
to those games we ain't trying to get
people in trouble yes you were adct yes
you
were I was referring to games that have
been announced I wasn't even thinking
about games that you know he knows that
we
don't I I will say for me personally in
the near term uh assassin Creed is one
of my favorite franchises just like
Final Fantasy so I'm excited for
Assassin's Creed Valhalla and I also
have to admit uh I'm really excited for
cyberp Punk oh yeah you know CD project
red is an incredible developer and I'm
just really excited to see what they're
going to bring with cyber Punk
absolutely absolutely I got to give this
one to the chat because it's a raging
debate they Super Chat was I have to ask
it because I have to respect the realm
with the recent announcement of the Mass
Effect Trilogy now tread carefully Jason
this is a very touchy sub subject very
emotional which Mass Effect is the
better Mass Effect between Mass Effect
one and Mass Effect two
oh you're trying to get me in trouble
I'm getting you in trouble
hooty is that better with my mic yes
okay if if I had to say it I'd say Mass
Effect to oh my the legend the legendary
the wizard of gaming the technical
Acumen he knows
Jason you was doing so good you was
doing so good you hear that chat do you
hear the creator of the series X has
told you what the law isre exist that
he's doing look at the that is my
personal preference I
have number one is the best I I got a
lot of flack from the community when I
said I liked Final Fantasy
13 that one hit me that one hit me hard
Jason man that just settles it I mean it
is what it is no it
doesn't nobody's perfect that's fine no
man and final I know we got to get you
getting close on time but just like
how's the energy from the team like you
know you're you're at the cusp all the
months I mean four years of development
and then two consoles super secretive
amazing two skew approach and now we're
at that week like is it finally sinking
in and how's the energy of the team as
get
closer yeah I mean the team's super
excited to your point you know the
team's been working really hard building
a new console generation is a tremendous
amount of work the last year of a
console launch is very exciting but
obviously to do it when we're all
working from home you know like I
haven't seen people on the team for
eight months at this point you know and
like we we didn't know how to build
consoles without sending people to the
factories we didn't know how to build
the operating system from our homes and
then obviously game development is super
challenging so like I couldn't be more
proud of how the teams come together
this year to continue to deliver on that
original Vision we set out four years
ago and to do it in a very difficult set
of circumstances um honestly you know
you said this week we actually launched
in 17 hours in New Zealand wow the very
country in the world so like we are
within the final 24 hours and I think
there's just tremendous amount of energy
within the team but more than anything
it's just really going to be getting in
the hands of players all around the
world that's what motivates us we're all
Gamers ourselves we've been playing on
these consoles for a while and it's now
to get it into your hands and get the
feedback from the community that is
pretty awesome you got myself waiting
out in front of GameStop for eight
hours no but I want I want to salute you
because you made a valid point and and
and Gamers we forget the human side of
this you know we are going through a
pandemic all protocols work from home
home conditions I work in it I know what
you're going through from a work from
home condition but I could I can't even
imagine how console development and
protocols significantly change and for
the team to be as agile as they are and
still get this thing across the Finish
Line has to be commended man salute to
you guys the work that you do the
transparency by team Xbox has been
amazing this generation so salute to you
man we're going to sign you off get
everybody on the realm talk to you and
where can it find people find you and
tell how excited we should be for this
launch yeah no and that's the thing is
so you know launches upon us the team's
going to be playing with the entire
community on November 10th uh so we're
just really excited to play with the
community and just make sure that uh
everybody's having a great time uh in
this difficult time for all of us no
doubt an absolute pleasure the tech
Wizard and Mass Effect one Guru Lord
Jason
Ronald from project manager of Team Xbox
man adct s let send our salutations off
to the to the Fine Lord yeah I you know
thank you for coming on Jason I know
especially you know on a Sunday and you
on the you on the west coast so this is
extra extra for you uh I know that this
you know took a lot especially how hard
you've been working on uh the LA launch
and for you to take time out of your day
to come and chill with us I appreciate
it and uh you know I'm sure our
community loves it too and uh I hope
nothing but the best for you and your
team thank you brother so
absolutely Jason I mean again for you to
take time out of your day to drive to
work and and and and join us today um it
it's it it exemplifies for me everything
that sort of Team Xbox has been doing
since the the the announcement of these
brand new consoles is very forward-
facing honest um approach to to to
talking to your fans and I think uh I I
think it really does show in the amount
of love and support you guys are getting
with the with the upcoming launch of
these consoles um it really the
engagement that you have with the
community matters to this community in a
way that I don't think you guys are
really going to see until until come
Tuesday or 17 hours as you said and
people are going crazy for these
consoles so thank you very much for all
the work you guys have done it it it's
like all your success is is very welld
deserved absolutely it's it's like I
said Lord Jason I have one coming to me
it's coming to me in three or four days
and I'm so extra I don't want wait I
want to have a day one so I have to wait
outside that that game St for like six
seven I get my hands on that call you're
funny you're too much luck Lord Jason
man thank you so much I'm sorry and I'll
definitely say from Team Xbox thank you
to all of you guys and everybody in the
community uh we really appreciate
everything that you guys do we
definitely listen to the community we're
part of the community ourselves so just
equally sharing that same positive
feedback to you guys to drive the
positive energy uh because we do it for
you guys much love brother again truly
humble truly hum enjoy your Sunday we
are hype we are on the Eve cannot wait
and hope to have you back in the future
as well to talk some more technical
terms from the series X and the series s
salute the legend Lord
Jason salute brother all right thank you
guys very much have a good one brother
cool see you man see you so there we
have it man let's get these uh super
chats man y there's there's a couple of
them um since we're a couple since we're
a couple Lords behind you want me to see
if I can get like forte in here we you
can work on Ian fine we're fine no I
mean like I'm just saying that while
you're doing the super you got do that's
fine I mean the main get this take care
business well I know that's why I was
just saying that I didn't want to bring
people and you you just got get you off
guard no worries no worries no no we
have Eagles fan 76 with a $5 Super Chat
can you guys maybe ask Jason this
question I want to use my Elite Series 2
as my controller will it have the same
latency response as a new controller got
yeah gotcha gotta gotcha I saw I notic I
noticed you worded that cuz to be honest
with you we got through questions way
quicker than I thought we I be honest
yeah I was I was trying to Breeze I
didn't know if we was going to and it
looked like we were in a good zone so I
just wanted to keep it flowing so I saw
the chat yeah I saw the chat and yeah
man it was it was cool so I you know you
know I had to try to take care of y'all
I saw it so salute you know what I'm
saying for people who tried to put stuff
in yeah then we have Eric Franklin with
the $25 Super Chat the series s back
compat is held back by the legacy of the
Xbox One's 900 uh 30 uh cap in many
games other than Fallout 4 will we see
any other series uh s Back compack Games
session or high resolutions that didn't
do on Xbox One we
got was keeping one eye on it I was like
you know what's funny I didn't even look
at it like I looked at it and I'm like
where can I fit this in and I'm like
I'll let Cog do it because Cog is
orchestrating the conversation so I'm
like he'll fit it I was talking to to
Cog yesterday and I was like just ask my
questions I want more I want a better
just ask my that was bad addict worldl
that was
bad forget about everyone look at you
trying to make this like about me you
don't understand how funny that sounded
you trying to make it about me okay give
me praise give me praise give mea to I
said for you to ask my questions have a
better conversation flow so we don't
waste time going through three different
parties thank you sirk you they trying
to I'm okay with you guys throw the
addict world but when it's not the
addict world I'm not okay with I
apologize I thought I thought you made
it into an adct world I was like that
was the funniest transformation that was
fun like selfish
like no doubt all right there we have uh
we have slowo backslide with the $5
Super Chat morning l so is Jason
confirming AMD super resolution their
version of Nvidia dlss is available on
Xbox series consoles I
listen he can't specifically say yeah I
imagine that as we get closer to what we
are going to be calling next gen games
we will see how those games are
developed and broken down and I'm sure
we're going to be hearing about this
more and more you got to remember guys a
lot of stuff is under NDA too and and
you know certain things they still they
can't speak on certain things yet but I
I I did see the super resolution I know
M's a couple people but I just I I
couldn't in in Fair fairness to the
situation yes I I had a feeling we
weren't going to get G get that yeah so
it's gonna be like you have to pick your
battles right the biggest thing that I
want the chat to realize is like when
you're scheduling for interviews and
stuff like this like we don't want the
the guests to feel like they're going to
just come on a show and get with a bunch
of questions that they can't answer like
we we we want a good engaging ation so
we try to stay away from the stuff that
we know for a fact exactly because again
it benefits no one time is wasted so
let's get some more productive questions
that we know figure that he can possibly
answer but yeah salute to y'all for that
though what else we got then we have GMD
geek with the $3 Super Chat I'm 200%
glad they did 1440p Native support too
yeah yeah abely a lot of people going to
be running these consoles on their uh on
PC monitors and whatnot so 1440p really
does help a lot and if you you have an X
running in 14 40p the down sampling is
going to look very pretty very
absolutely then we have Dan de man
Cunningham with the $2 Super Chat as
Jason Mass Effect one to we asked the
question who took care of you wait hold
on I I gotta get y'all Gotta Throw to
who did that for you for me for y'all
questions so because I I snuck some you
know that wasn't on the agenda but I had
to start trouble with that mass effect
effect I need who did that for you man
you got to put Cog up in there man yeah
C looked out for y out for the let me
address something in the chat real quick
I see there's a bunch of stuff going on
in that chat look the console war
stuff's cool you know you can do little
petty jokes in there but like if you
that's all that you're posting our our
mods are gonna get you anybody that got
a wrench is on
you we don't there's actually not a lot
of people with a wrench we really don't
mod
anyone no no continue thank you for the
all who did that for yall y I appreciate
y'all man salute salute you know it's
always love you know that what else we
got then we have Rising grind with the
$5 Super Chat thank you sir much appreci
oh salute that's the Hobie we got our
man Neo gam spark with a $10 Super Chat
Sunday is the Lord's Day shout out to
the iron realm welcome Jason I've been
using the series X and I salute every
single person on the team for crafting a
dope ass machine best wishes on launch
fantastic oh that's the homie shout out
to spark right now man he's doing big
big that's my guy right there so we know
we gonna get you back in the real too
brother then we got family went away
Dragon TV with the5 Super Chat what's
good my brothers Lord lemon in the
building Jason we all excited for the
launch of Xbox series X great job and
the community has y'all back all day
lemon I'm not sure my brother but since
you were talking about uh you know a
Theater seating and stuff like that my
assumption is you're getting some crazy
crazy projector that's that's my
assumption you already know how he play
we'll see you on Tuesday we'll see you
on Tuesday shout out to 108 brother see
you man see you man much love support
his channel man he's doing a lot of
stuff from a technical standpoint
helping a lot of content creators
getting started getting the right
equipment getting the audio getting your
your set up together so if you need help
please reach out to 108 dragons
subscribe to the channel man boy even
help me out help me step our game up
when we out there in the field on the
interviews man 108 I see you bro
Brooklyn stand up you already know
salute for sure for sure for sure then
we got our brother boom double barrel
gaming with the $10 super my brothers
are killing it I'm so proud of you guys
while Jason Ronald and I M blone thank
you my brother bro yo boom thank you so
much you know we couldn't do it without
y'all Y you guys the likes the retweets
the love y'all give the community spoom
you've always been a supporter for us
from day one to it allows us to have
opportunities like this we're not the
biggest but we punch above our weight
and we feel we can hang so to hear it
from you guys truly humbling thank you
so much that means everything yes and
because of the celebration be looking at
that chat I'm about to drop a code in
thatat let
get
got
continue I'm not dring it yet I I want
people I want people to uh see random
okay okay all right and we got black
Ronin 357 with the $5 Super Chat the
wizard blessed us with some facts trivia
and good opinion on Xbox and gaming yes
the wizard yes he did legendary let me
get clutch man with the F Super Chat
can't watch live but just sliding in a
question is there a world on how and
when consoles will go on sale at stores
J boy I don't think Jason can answer
that one yeah I'm honestly under the
impression I I was at a Best Buy
yesterday and they said they're not
having any in store um you know like
basically they don't have any extras in
store I would check anyway um obviously
you guys heard I think uh um Walmart is
doing some stuff where I'm assuming they
have in store and you can order online
and maybe you'll be able to pick up same
day or the following day um so that's
the way they're doing it but we we shall
see but some people will have some
people won't right no doubt no doubt you
know what I'm saying what else we got
and I I dropped the code in there all
right cool Go Get It Go Get It I got
Mortal Kombat
11 I don't be playing those head toad
Fighters but I hear they're popular
shout out to the aftermath you know what
I'm saying uh then we got GMD geek with
the $20 Super Chat looking forward to AI
machine learning being applied to gaming
evaluating and fire teams Loadout XP uh
in an instant and spawning an instance
encounter more challenging for them uh
can AI machine learning keep games
exciting relevant longer thoughts uh
again he gave us an idea of how that's
going to be happening moving forward but
again that's why it excites me so much
this is when you talk about something
that seems like it's magic is Magic and
it allows these machines to sort of
punch above their weight imagine getting
to a point and we've we've only seen
like we've only seen it in in in video
stuff and whatnot but they had games
running at sub 720P upscale to 4K with
very little difference in that and and
and Native 4K that is Bonkers because
then all that performance overhead can
go to can go to yeah better image
quality texture image quality all that
other stuff so it's it allows these
machines to really punch above that's
why it's funny you said that because
that's why we can't get too crazy with
the native resolution stuff as more
because image quality is key if if they
can do more things with image quality
hey take break down that that overhead
and and get and use those resources
elsewhere and then still give me that
hot frame rate I'm with that you know
what I'm saying but let me get let me
get Eagles fan because I think this one
was for me man cheat cheating it was
only us only I'm sorry you guys there's
only so much the Lords could do you know
region stuff is like always an issue and
I apologize for that it's all good it's
all good let me get Eagles fan 765 Super
Chat thanks IP for the question you
already know does this change how you
feel about using the elite elite
controls until there's an update or you
going to try a both I don't know that's
a good question I mean the elite is just
so so good um I felt Jason's answer when
he said you can map it but I think there
is something like that ease of use of
the share just being there so I don't
know I gotta see I got I gotta
experiment I got to get both of my hands
before you know what I'm saying I can
see you know so that's what it is so so
putting it to a back pedals like good
enough for you that's that's an extra
step yeah I'm not about that that's why
listen I got a play and charge kit
because I'm gonna be using the the core
one when it out of the box and then once
we get the update then I'll go back no
doubt no doubt shout out get get Neo get
ne up there uh Neo again we
have guys are being way too grateful to
this week yeah love Yeah you got show M
love we have Dan the Man Cunningham with
the $5 Super Chat oh hell Lord Cognito
thank you sir much love to you all in
good fun of course you already know I
already know I'll take over for a couple
you've been reading for like 40
minutes we got we got a $5 Super Chat
from 108 Dragon David get better bro did
I say it right no no you're right you're
right my bad oh Jesus Jesus Christ my
bad my bad I forgot I didn't know what
better bro wish you was here proud of
you guys a real positive podcast setting
the example for the industry and I type
in caps CU I'm excited so don't want
dragon in caps let's go we got we got a
$10 Super Chat from Alvin story was
great and spent 700 plus hours in the
multiplayer best is Mass Effect 3 no
question first now we'll give you this
Mass Effect 3's multiplayer is the best
multiplayer out of you know well one
didn't even
abely continue not I got I Gotta Throw
My slander so I got it's so good that
they kicked it out of
this we got we got a we got a super chat
for Mars man one of the fellow Lords he
said fantastic show as always the reason
I didn't say that currency Mo because I
have absolutely no idea what that Curr
shout out to Poland stand up yo mod I
got you you know I saw you on the frame
rate on the back compack game I got you
bro trust me but I couldn't do the super
resolution but I got you on the frame
rates and it looks like there's
something that they can still do with
stuff that's locked which is pretty
impressive continue yeah so we got a $5
Super Chat from Michael AKA bet the
finest I don't know if I probably
butcher that my apologies King is sick
so I will be Petty for him so
PlayStation 5 can't do Native 1440p but
this is the system people are going
crazy for laugh my off uh trash station
look man King's Army is going to take up
the realm for him good Gerald M we got a
$5 super from jaac I told cats on
Twitter the IOP is doing big things
shout out to the Lords I appreciate you
guys we try man we try appreciate you
what else we got and the the chat
completely shift okay we got a $5 Super
Chat let me make sure yeah from Neo
gamespark Lords of the realm do you know
when the tanks will be restocked it's a
big boy size and I need my 2x tanks oh
yeah yeah hold on oh you need 2x we I
thought we check on that on the store we
should have the yeah oh shout out to
forat building I see you brother pulled
up I you know what I'm saying it's got
the camera on and all that um yeah we
should have the big boy joints I will
double check though and let me know
which one you want like cuz we got the
um we got the flavors baby we got you
want the log you want the IOP so let me
know but I think we should be fine maybe
it's the size we don't have I'll double
check though so we got a $10 Super Chat
from the commissioner Sony commissioner
himself
Optimus imagine quality is the key I can
retire and peace outy oh image oh no I
said
that see what happens is I read it so
fast that I always be like it is not
it's okay your boy's an idiot your boy's
an idiot so we Okay we okay you know you
know me and you agree on that part you
know what I'm saying like image quality
is key and I know we're we're so used to
the the N the game is so used to the
900p 1080p thing and it's it's a
different gen man it's a different thing
things are going to different techniques
going to make it you can pick up because
I cannot pronounce his name to save my
life we have we have Mar with the5 see I
can say that but I can't say it with
that
extr awesome interview Lords can't wait
for the day you guys get Phil Spencer on
the putting out into the universe thank
you Lord put it out put the dominance in
the Phil you know we'd love to have you
in the realm you know king would love to
have in the you say if you got the time
we'd love to have to talk with you again
thanks to you guys again you guys always
help us get these things if it wasn't
for your support we would not be where
we are so we super appreciative so thank
you Nine Lives someone said he said is
addict using the Dual sense mic is it
sound that bad you sound a little uh
yeah a little like a robotic you roboted
at the end what Jason well I I apologize
you guys next week it'll be handled what
I need to do is I need to get off my
lazy self and and wire that ethernet
cord to my PC but you but I you have
your you have your your headphone mic up
maybe it's using both of them both yeah
no I hooked it completely just now all
right anyway time Super Chat let's go
got get we have uh Italian clowns with
the $2 Super Chat our brother and he has
something for the reals there's a Code
there if you got that code from Italian
clowns uh no clue what it was shout out
into the uh in the in the chat give a
big up to Italian clowns for doing that
for the for the real salute hey salute
to four guys with quarters man salute
he's out here moving had a great
interview with the ble told Dev and a
voice actor or actress excuse me and we
are we caught up yet what else we got
yeah no we have 108 once again with the
$2 Super Chat sa no projector but the TV
will shock you oh now I'm super
intrigued all right then we have we have
one more we have Stitch with the $2
Super Chat we need native support for
Ultra widescreen monitors yeah that
would that would be crazy all right man
we are all caught up so we got to get
pay the bills man yeah we got to pay the
bills as you know we didn't do our
regular patreon giveaway and our YouTube
giveaway last week because we were
focusing on on the big boys get getting
out there so uh as I say every month
thank you guys for all the support that
you guys give us this is because of you
so this is how we give back to you so
we're going to start off and as you know
since no bag was dropped off this week
I'm I'm I'm gonna make sure that you
guys know that there's no there's no
funny business going on here so I'm
going to go ahead and share I think
y'all got giving people the wrong
address that's why that b for
I swear swear the address I got was U
was uh wasn't a PO
Box you told me you was like yo why
didn't your stuff and I can't help that
your check didn't go through like it's
not my fault like man I was like look
man I C I personally called that man I
was like look man what
happened what's going on yeah
not failed me you failed me man what we
got s get the B let me do the screen
share real quickly let me go to the
random name picker are you guys seeing
that yeah man I got you you good okay
all right so the winner of our $10 uh
Whatchamacallit uh gift card giveaway is
hit the
button wait what did I do at least I see
my name this time oh my
God
scrub that sound better you guys
you sound like wor yeah go back to what
you was doing scrub nurse salute
congrats uh scrub nurse you know howat
me on uh on Twitter in the DMS all right
so now the winner of our $20 gift card
giveaway
is go that creeps me out every time you
do that every time you do that spy
on Sparty on Salute No Doubt party uh
get at me in in DMS and we will take
care of you with that gift card no doubt
um and now does that sound better yes
yes cleaner definitely all right now
onto our Teespring giveaway let's get
that dri the winner of our Teespring
giveaway
ISP
Mich fantastic so Michael get at me um
if you have you're on YouTube and you
know you don't have any other sort of
means of of contacting get at me on at
Lord IOP on Twitter um and I will get
you all the information that uh to to
get your stuff out to you because uh
Teespring is actually better now people
are getting their stuff on time on time
yeah in the time really blame them
though like that that was during the pic
yeah it it was it was crazy but like
people were waiting like two months for
this stuff like and then they weren't
telling us that there was an issue that
was their that was definitely their
fault they should have been more
transparent they should have took a took
a a a page out of Microsoft
slings what else we got so uh that
that's it on that um as I was saying
right before Jason came on big shout out
to key will 26 for his uh donation of
three months of Game Pass ultimate to
the winner of our Xbox series X big bad
Mo so I will uh Mo I will get that to
you Lo on the screen you're cool is all
your CO's all the way loose
okay my bad there you go there you go
let me let me hit the stop sharing yeah
how about that how about you stop
snitching on yourself and giving up
codes there you
go that that that's oh man yeah it is
what it is it's a
w if guys don't do that guys don't do
that you know it's if the iron bank will
replace
it so we all set up with yeah we're all
set up once again thank you guys and
congratulations to the winners um like I
said you guys we cannot do this without
you no doubt no doubt so you already
know so look we got to get this poll
popping got a couple things going on
with the topics we got Lord forte in the
realm salute BR podcast DPS podcast you
know what I'm saying what's going on
Forte how you doing sir a man I'm good
you know it's a rare day that I'm not
sitting in the store um getting ready
for you know they gave us um they gave
us um schedules we had to like really
support this week and I was like man can
I just have like Tuesday and Thursday
off and then I thought about I was like
oh PlayStation comes out on Thursday can
I have Friday like oh Call of Duty comes
out on Friday I'm like f yeah I was like
well I guess I got to take Sunday off
then so but it's always good because the
Lords when the Lords call I can come
appreciate you brother I know it's we
get you so we had to get that in I don't
know if you can answer this but um uh oh
one day early two days early will you be
having extras in stores every store will
have extras okay okay I can answer that
I just can't tell you how
many no doubt let's get into this poll y
we got a lot of show left we just got to
get this thing rolling last week poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with Halo
infinite losing another top director
during his development cycle which
course of action do you think 343 should
take when releasing the game the winner
of the four-way ILP poll at 56% of the
vote was delayed until the completed
version of Halo infinite is ready coming
in at second at 20% % was I don't care
it's y'all fault for bullying
Craig third place at 14% was separate
Halo infinite single player and
multiplayer and last place at 8% of the
vote was scrap the initial Vision
entirely remake with a new graphics
engines group Lord Forte your thoughts
sir on what the people said say
something real quick yeah yeah hurry up
before I jump off yes the biggest thing
I love is when someone wins something
there in the chat live Michael Owens
said Sovereign that was a total shock I
will give you my details after the show
finishes salute salute salute what's up
for yep so everybody that said separate
the game jump jump off the Ambassador
Bridge jump off of whatever bridge is in
your state jump off
of whatever just make sure there's no
make sure there's nothing there to catch
you that is like listen man we can't be
giving that type of energy to Microsoft
they already about it yes they we're
thinking about doing like no we when you
think Halo you don't think just one part
of the game you think of the whole thing
I don't want part of the game I want to
be able to enjoy the single player and
pivot to the multiplayer and when all of
those fraudulent people that don't play
Halo day one want to say hey yo can play
the campaign with me I can go back and
play the campaign with them at any time
and stuff so I don't want it to be
separate it's look man everybody knows
that the game needs to be delayed as
long as poss possible how long some
people probably think it's only going to
be to like the end of the year I think
this game ain't coming out next year
this game ain't coming out to 2022 I
think there's too many now unless
they're not making the major changes
that a lot of people think they're
making because I think they're
completely overhauling that game to an
extent where it won't look
unrecognizable but the things that
they're doing you got to think about it
they delayed a game that was literally
coming out in a month or two months at
that time so what they have to really
show out with that game when they
finally do show it again so I think
they're gonna take a lot of time to make
sure that they are unapproachable when
it comes to what that game looks like
yes what that story is going to be and
how that multiplayers is going to feel
and trust me they G to make sure that
game has not a s probably not a single
bug but to the point where bugs are like
one% of the game at that point that's
the type of State I think that game
needs to release in when they show it
again so 2022 probably early I don't
think they'll have a chance to wait till
the holiday but think about it all and
it sucks because they have a bunch of uh
they have no other games really on the
horizon to really look forward to for
first party so a lot of people don't
want to hear that but that's what I
would tell people that's what you should
be hoping for if the game could come out
earlier then we good but it needs to
come out in a perfect state so people
can actually believe in the Halo
franchise all over again I perfect State
and complete State especially with it
was not received so I'm with you for T
man let's get any super chats because I
gota go into the topic we good uh yeah
we got a couple super chats we have
first
of uh we have scrub nurse shout out to
scrub nurse I'll get i'll get your code
to you later on listening to the podcast
while putting in that OT shout out to
the Lords and all that in the chat then
we have Stitch with the two $3 super
chat now I'm intrigued about the games
he knows about Ian yeah he did say got
to know about everything probably see
any initiatives Butters he probably I
really wasn't trying to do like some
some like spy you some nefarious stuff
yeah I I was really on that I just want
to know what he's the most like I
thought it was gonna be like something
like fa I wasn't asking yo what's the
games you ain't announced
yet it's we have one we havei with the
$5 Super Chat Mass Effect one over all
else it went downhill after that wasn't
even RPG after one last I said you
already heard what the wizard said like
it's it's over for y'all like the
creator of the series X already deemed
it so it's like the Bible and on the
first day Mass Effect 2 was decided the
amount the amount the amount of talking
of this Mass Effect we're gonna have to
give a mass effect no we do we G to do a
mass effect we're gonna do a mass effect
special podcast I'm get a padle together
a couple people it's going to be L
that's going to be the best weekend
gaming right there when that game comes
out actual slowo holl at me we know we
riding
anyway yeah well wasn't even one hold on
let me finish this one up we have Su
Lords sup Forte Jesus Glover got a chin
in thiago's power yeah I didn't I fraud
it last I didn't watch any UFC I only
watched the Boza fight versus um oroski
I didn't get a chance to see them are
you guys when it comes to the mass
effect that you gonna wait for the game
to be out for a little bit Yeah like a
week before I would say or you if you
give me enough time to beat it all right
cool so what we could do is we could
wait yeah we could wait like the week
after but thing is the anti we'll talk
with time on myself we'll talk about
that after the J question is are you
going to wait till people beat all three
right that's the thing yeah you know
what I that's one thing I thought about
that's 30 hours per game almost we
should do more podcast with like
breaking down games like we should
definitely do that and our debates are
fire even when disagrees with
me no you don't need to be breeding that
Among Us energy in here when we play
Among Us it's always addict's fault oh
we caught up because we got to move on
no we got Alvin with the $5 Super Chat
they said they're updating the game over
10 years it can't be complete on day one
because of the nature of what the game
is times are a changing that's true then
we got J du is a shill no we have black
Ronin first off we have black Ronin with
the $5 Super Chat should I camp out a
GameStop or try ordering online at the
other retailers camp out camp out that's
the guaranteed way
yeah early yeah if you get the thing is
if you can guarantee yourself most
stores I don't know every store but most
stores supposed to put signs on their
door to let people know how many they
have so they can avoid people camping
out overnight for no reason if you can
walk up to a door and you're like one of
the first three or four people then I
would stay there until the store opens
no doubt no doubt all set so you can be
there about 10 hours we all set we got
JD is aill with the $5 Super Chat Lord
Sovereign please don't make fun of me I
I'm new to this stuff and I got your
message yeah J awesome yes sir please
collect your PlayStation 5 thank you sir
you won it we have one more we have JD
gamer no we have two more we have JD
gamer with the $5 Super Chat just wanted
to say congratulations to the ILP on
your Jason Ronald come up Forte I'll be
waiting outside of your GameStop to get
that series
X why I gotta be his GameStop
you then we have Mike Mike AR Archangel
80 with the $5 Super Chat uh it's skew
Forte have you tried Xbox series X with
the ultra wide monitor I wish I wish I
know I know I wish they won't give us
Ultra wide support I know it hopefully
it then we got then we got Lord FS being
messy the grounded gamer with the $2
Super Chat Halo infinite remains trash
until proven otherwise oh my God F you
know what you've been messing on RDX too
F I've been seeing
you let's be 100% real he's on to
something with that if you if you show
me more on making the game look bad than
you show me on making the game look good
I had to assume it's ladder time we've
done beat Halo into the death have are
we caught up yes we all right we got
show to do anyway so we got the medium
up y'all so um look look like the
statement was made shout out to blueberg
team so after much careful thought and
consideration today they have made the
difficult decision to delay the launch
of the medium to January 28th and the
reason why they said it wasn't an easy
choice to make but one made due to the
covid-19 situation in Poland as well as
the current schedule of other games on
the market blue team remains committed
to delivering our F biggest most
ambitious fear inducing experience to
date so then that that was the main
statement that went out on Twitter so I
want to bring this to the realm real
quick um you know one was this the right
move to move their date you know what
I'm saying because of cyber Punk um or
should they have stayed on their date
because they're kind of in The Game Pass
Lane because I know I've had this
discussion with King before we on kind
of opposite sides of the fence here so
let's get the guess I don't know how
long Forte's got with us so Forte like
where you at man do you think they
should have there was the right move get
away oh man they they as soon as cyber
Punk dropped in their lap it was like yo
we here I don't know what you gonna
do we but we here and we me and youai
was in a party talking about this was
like yo bro they gonna have to move you
know what's funny I think by hook or
crook they gonna have to move I don't
care if they in game p listen you got to
this is the whole narrative them being
the only XBox exclusive game that was
going to be
available in any time frame of the
system coming out outside of of course
um um gears tactics yes them being the
only one would have got so much media
attention because they was like yo
Xbox's first game that they releas and
that's next gen coming to Game Pass and
what happens the biggest game of the
year literally drops in their lap so now
all the articles that day are going to
be about oh cyber Punk how does it run
what what is the um what's the low
screens looking like you gonna see like
a thousand articles that day the whole
week is goingon to be about cyber pun
nobody be thinking about the median so
they needed to move it so if they could
take that time to polish the game to
make it a little look a little bit
better I don't think they're really
doing anything this is
just this is them just using using the
whole we need to delay the Polish for
reasons to get the heck away from a
8,000 pound gorilla I'm with them they
needed to do this and only delayed it
what a month basically yeah to J January
21st which I think is probably even
better day for them because it comes
it's going to hit right before February
where a lot of people like most other
like what Far Cry comes out around that
time so you give yourself like two three
weeks before farry got pushed got pushed
oh got pushed oh yes right they got
pushed so they gave thems a basically a
month and a half away from cyberp Punk
so by that point people that did play
cyber Punk will probably be looking for
something else to play that's a little
bit different so I think this is a good
move but it kind of had to happen CD
Project R forced their hand on this one
yeah what you think it it's like wasn't
there a game that pushed himself back a
forward a little bit a couple days like
I remember uh pillar uh pillars of
fraternity they have an expansion coming
out and they they pushed their game a
little bit they the first time they
delayed it they pushed their game
because they delayed at that time and
then it's funny because then they delay
their game again Cy Punk does so then
they delay their game again because of
cyber
Punk yeah B so they have delayed their
game two times over cyber
Punk it's inter been sof where you at
was it the right move or could Game Pass
could have held it down for them and man
I got I gotta disagree with King on that
one like they needed to move regardless
of game passes like Forte said like no
matter what the the the conversation
that day is going to be cyberpunk no
matter what and I appreciate that in
their statement they stated yeah certain
other games coming out they said it like
like they said it like no man
like respect like no I'm out of here
listen you guys remember what happened
to rise of the Tomb Raider when it
launched the same day as Fallout 4 like
it was what's wrong with you what are
you
doing and and they doubled down on that
date and it was like why are you doing
this um no you walk you walk away walk
you walk away from the 800 pound Gill
you don't have that you don't fight the
800 pound gorilla you don't do that yo
go Toe to Toe with them dudes Toe to Toe
with them game off but Game Pass you saw
what happened to Titan
tit maybe it's maybe it's a little
better because of Game Pass but at the
same time it's like why take the chance
like like you might get a little bit
more I mean you'll never know because
obviously we can't live in alternate
realities but it's just like why take
the chance of losing some sales when you
could just delay it a month and get
those sales anyway so like and you know
you might delay yourself out of the
holiday completely which they did and
get way more sales because you're not
competing with half the market and
that's even the sales thing aside right
it's just mind share if nobody's talking
about your game today it launches and
remember cyber Punk is a game that
people gonna be talking about not for a
day not for a week it could be a months
right but at the very least you give
yourself that distance that you have
your own date to yourself like barring
that barring the fact that any other
game decides to launch on their new
launch date um they have it to
themselves and the fact that it is sort
of that sort of XBox exclusive directly
into Game Pass people are going to want
to hear what this game is and how good
it is right and if it's a good game too
you don't want it to get buried
absolutely I agree I agree I mean look
you know shout out to King I know he's
going at it and stuff like this and um I
definitely heard heard we was trying to
go with with the whole you know the game
pass thing but again it's like for said
like to me it's it's just even from the
simple standpoint of the news and the
Press media run that will smother you
when that game when cyber Punk drops it
it's just it's a different thing and to
to be real with you s like it's few
games that could straight Debo you out
your spot like Call of Duty is one of
them games right you don't really want
to be around that joint I would think
maybe what like a Last of Us two or a
God of War you know what I'm saying like
they literally roll up on that date and
mush
and like get out get
out it would be different if we haven't
seen actual scenarios were a game flops
because they don't do it we saw Tomb
Raider get obliterated because of
Fallout 4 they felt like they were
worthy enough and they were they that
they were tall enough to compete with
Fallout 4 see EA do it to themselves
themselves with Titan for like yeah at
the end of the day look man shout out to
Blue Team for standing tall on it like
keeping it true with the press release
like yo fam I love the facts off they
even said do the other games do exactly
admit the truth admit the trth cuz we
know it's the truth so you ain't fooling
nobody and that's why I got to respect
bloa team I've never seen that level of
transp except one developer and addict
knows shout out to um the original
creators of XCOM that's making that game
Phoenix Point yo why we got the press
release from Lords and ging right shout
out to Phoenix fight shout out to APR
they like yo um we ain't even BSU y'all
y'all know why we moving from
DEC they they they they straight up said
no one's going against cyberp Punk so we
moving up a week early so you could go
cop us before yo salute the joks I
respect it I respect it listen with big
Debo project red come through you gotta
move baby you got to move who bike is
that it's they bike get out the
way get out the way you know what I'm
saying it could have been it it could
have been been a little different if it
was a physical release with this being
the digital only yeah um it's easier to
move the game when you're not really
yeah you're trying to go after sales for
the holiday but they're not going to
sell as much as a game that's going to
be physically in a store where hundreds
of people are walk in and they see them
and that's where people like impost buy
a lot and plus the game's not going to
be on sale because the game is Just
releasing and it's in Game Pass so
they're looking like we're still going
to get the
visibility January just like we're going
to get in December because we're not on
a store fret we're in a digital
ecosystem so we're not losing anything
there and probably think about it Game
Pass what's their subscription um what's
their subscription number going to be
after the holiday how many more people
that are buying Xboxes this holiday are
going to be getting gay PS over the
holiday versus now is it possible that
gay cats can add another two three
million people over the next month facts
yeah and and if they do that's more
people seeing them so they're so look
they they smart about it but trust me
they they said it right in the release
we're moving because of this one thing
and let's just hope it works out on the
other side facts man gotta love it and I
always feel like I I like when games do
that like what that first quarter that
January to March I always feel that's a
sweet spot see I think gaming sometimes
Forte I don't know if you agree with me
like sometimes they they try to pack
everything in that holiday November
December and as a gamer I that's why I
tweeted the like selfishly I'm like I'm
happy cuz you giv me a chance to breathe
I could space these releases out from a
Content creative standpoint as well as a
game enjoyment standpoint so salute the
blue man I think they did the right
thing man but that's what I got anything
else before we move on any chats
anything else before we move on sir are
we all good sir well that's crazy good
hold on second um the I know this
completely gaming unrelated the dude who
hosted Jeopardy for all those years just
died oh Alex
rebec passed away I was just thinking
about that that we hadn't heard from him
and I know his battle his battle with
cancer was he kind of quiet it's all
over Twitter right now rest in peace I
back man that's my childhood Jeopardy
grew up with that man Daily Double man
double that that's that's that hits home
Alex for back hard year so far man0 has
looking up now at the end but it's it's
hard still hard I agree man what's up
anything else we got okay yeah we got
two super chats we have Spartan go 17
with the two pound Super Chat I'm here
for the needs to be collected Lord s oh
well
um is here for me to collect his knes so
I don't know what needes you're talking
about because they're saying they're
saying you you've lost the king that's
the new rhetoric now I don't know people
are really good at making
things it feels like they've gone to the
Donald Trump School
online politics but um no no no no King
King is refusing to give me his knees
and that's fine he can hold on to him as
long as he want he don't want to concede
no he don't know there's no
concession moving away from
politics we superat we have Michael Jr
with the $5 Super Chat this game moved
out the way as fast as L did when
avoiding them
knes these two tag teaming and all I can
say is that King really has you
brainwashed because I some of that money
that King makes back from consoles that
he sells on eBay I'm going need him to
you know get you guys some reading
lessons I just don't seem to
understand
we when the concerts are out officially
out next week we're gonna have to like
like completely put this bed away
entirely I'm so confus there's nothing
to put the bed
over
over that you will say your case next
week off like I didn't agree to any of
the stuff that was said in that bet so
it don't apply to me I agre I agree I I
am on soft side like how do you how is
there a bet when there's no agreement by
both parties you can talk all you want
you blah blah blah blah blah blah it
didn't mean nothing to me like anyway
moving on speaking of speaking of uh the
Lord King himself this is his topic man
we got to talk about Sega and he wanted
to bring this to the realm um shout out
to them um looks like Sega Sammy man
arcade business is looks like they're
selling the arcade business is to gender
Inc never heard of gender Inc so yeah
looks like s why they selling it don't
you why are they selling this it's
because Microsoft don't need oh here we
go Sega Samy has announced it will sell
the majority of shares in its Sega
entertainment division to Japanese
Amusement rental business gender Inc so
the announcement went out to the
shareholders today and um yeah man just
I guess covid and then the struggles
with the closures of sega's famous I
can't pronounce this akih Haba harabara
okay a aabra you know what I'm saying
and um yeah so it looks like that is
going down uh looks like gab industry. B
shout out to them with the article they
broke it as far as reach out to Sega for
comments so uh King brought this to the
realm and he wanted to discuss the
implications of this and also in typical
King fashion how it may relate to
Microsoft so Lord Forte let's get right
into it man are they right for the
picking should pH swoop in man okay so
what so basic what everybody think how
do we know if they haven't already swop
oh yeah what okay so the thing is
normally when a company is getting ready
to get absolved by another company when
it's bigger all your assets usually
freeze in place you don't make any
drastic changes um to the company
because you want because people have to
go in and they have to evaluate
everything to make sure everything's on
the up and up that's why you don't see
any major movings that's why especially
like perfect example like when Gamestop
was trying to get um bought they didn't
want to do anything until the they until
the CEO was in place because all that
stuff has to be structured so the
company know that comes in is they know
what they're getting so the fact that
they sold this off right now kind of
LEDs to the fact that they're not going
through an acquisition phase right now
because they wouldn't be changing
anything that drastic in their bottom
line I just think just like they said
due to co like that's probably one part
of their business is the arcade side of
it that is really struggling a lot um
they're doing really well when it comes
to everything else but just like every
other company you got parts that are
doing really well and really bad and
then you're just like okay well we want
to remain profitable throughout this
holiday we want to post on the green
side not the red side and if we cut this
now it's a possibility that that
overhead could get absorbed by what we
do throughout the rest of the year uh
and it also could be a preparation of
knowing that acquisition is coming up
within the next count of the year so
they want to get their books in in order
before that starts taking place right so
it doesn't say that it can't happen it
just says as of right now don't look for
Sega to be purchased by anybody within
the next six to seven months because
they wouldn't make this change right now
if that was the case because that
company would want to assess everything
they have right now as a business if
they're going to acquire them in the
next couple of months right fair enough
fair enough Lord the addict is he step
away he still there see C's off he may
have stepped away so let's get right
into saw man what do you think man what
what's the realisticness of this well I
don't know if you guys remember I don't
remember if we talked about it on the
show or we just talked about it on the
side but do you remember a couple of
months ago that they Sega was talking
about kind of uh using the cloud to sort
of project all of their arcade stuff to
homes and this was sort of the response
to covid and people not being able to go
to into the arcades obviously that is a
humongous undertaking to do in a couple
of months and sort of shift all of that
in a way that's meaningful and allows
you to continue your business so I don't
think I I obviously it seems like none
of that panned out and you know they
they C had the sort of abandoned ship so
the thing about it is that it it seems
like they're going to continue to make
arcade games the thing is that genda
will be will purchase those games now as
opposed to them having to foot the bill
for for for having the locations and
continuing to run those machines much
like they did when they exited the the
hard of business long ago it's just them
sort of producing games and and selling
them out um so it does make a hell of a
lot of sense for them considering the
situation they were in right now how
that bodes for them may be being
purchased at some point um I do think it
makes it more interesting because now
they've sort of absolved themselves of
this entire aspect of their of their
business and basically mostly focusing
on home Council development not to cut
you saw but wasn't the point of
contention before that the reason why
Microsoft might not be interested was
because they had these other Ventures
whether it be Arcane and all that stuff
so if that I get I got to give my boy
King some love some love here like with
that part being now out of the question
I do hear what Forte is saying he is
right as far as not you know usually
doing these type of moons if you're
looking to be Qui we gonna get it we
gonna get it but my thing I know I see
Stitch but the thing is like you know
that division that wasn't really of
interest to Microsoft now that it's gone
do you think that may play a factor
here um absolutely because again it's
it's nice and clean and neat now right
it's neat to be snatched is exactly it's
very nice and neat you know if if if
Microsoft would to be interested in them
or anybody in the in the the the regular
gaming space would be interested in them
it would need to be that focus on the
console gaming right and those Studios
that are making games for console and PC
so everything else um is something they
wouldn't want and being that that the
way Sega is structured all of this is
sort of together under one umbrella they
would have needed to do that so like
like Forte said this could be a
harbinger of what's to come them sort of
cleaning house and making sure they have
that one Focus so they look more
appealing to somebody willing to
purchase them um do I would I love
Microsoft to take them absolutely I
again we've said this for for years now
uh to me when Sega left the the console
business the Xbox sort of became that
platform the the surrogate ex Sega I
agree so for me to have them in that
ecosystem and to have you know the way
Phil sort of runs things where it's like
you guys do your thing here is here's
money do your thing um the the games
will be going in the game pass and to
see the possibility of all of those old
franchises coming back in some way shape
or form is is interesting and fantastic
because to me on their own they're gonna
pick and choose what they bring back
right they're going to keep making Sonic
because that makes the money regardless
of the quality of the game you know
things like that um obviously Yakuza big
for them Yak is getting big in the west
now so that's huge um yeah so they are
sort of right for the picking by a sort
of Western platform holder to sort of
bring them into the fold and and bring
the Sega name back up to what it used to
be and you
know King isn't being delusional about
this either so it's like there is there
is a lot of like solid things going
around that would really make you think
Microsoft is acquiring or if not have
already acquired them like I said um
there is a rumor that they bought Sega
and remember that rumor that Sega is
supposed to take over the the Xbox brand
in
Japan yeah yeah I remember that so I
mean and then uh they're right now in
the past month they have been taking
sega's name off buildings in
Japan look so I mean that's weird you
got the fact that all of a sudden it's
not just been one or two games it's been
multiple games right that's coming to
the to Game Pass and now we got uh this
new Yak is is an exclusive to the next
gen Xbox platform for right so it's just
like there's a lot of things that is
really starting the point that's like
you know there might be something going
on here I don't know if it's a purchase
I don't know if it's not a purchase and
to be honest with you like you know uh I
do think that's something that they
would consider doing yeah get you super
chats then I'll jump in uh we have stits
with the5 chat KNE for knee solve is
losing I I don't KN for KN he demanding
a knee recount there's no need to
recount there's no need there's no
recount needed it's a r on you today I
think I think I think he he's saying
that you're the Trum King is sick and
the realm is like nah we riding y but
the thing is y gota remember yall not
built for
this me me and King go at it cuz we both
built for it y'all don't want that
really
don't you know I know King makes y'all
feel
confident y don't want to smoke with me
spicy spicy let's just let's just let's
be real we we know exactly what type of
toppings he gonna eat your
new let's get the rest of the Super Chat
yeah then we got Ray G4 with the 2 Super
Chat get well King no doubt doubt I
think King King is I think he's been
able to be like a little bit kind of in
Twitter whatnot so he's he's he's kind
of awake watch distance then we got JD
gamer with the $5 Super Chat Microsoft
is not buying SGA with pinko Machin I
yeah IE they don't want the Sammy part
of Sega no need or desire for it
Microsoft is not into gambling yes Sega
Sammy they don't they want or need that
part now the Samy stuff is interesting
though because then you get into all
like the Guilty Gear and stuff like
that I want that yeah I yeah give me
that give me that all right so we caught
up we caught up we caught up we are
caught up I forgot that's a company that
could make Killer Instinct no doubt yeah
man look at the end of the day you know
for me it's like it's a glimmer of hope
you know what I'm saying but I'm kind of
leaning towards Forte right now look I'm
a nostalgic I'm a Sega kid but it's like
at this point it's just like I got to be
on look do do I want it to happen
absolutely you know what I'm saying but
realistically you also we got to look at
it too like sometimes it's like it
reminds me of the bun of deal and say
sometimes like what the fans want might
not necessarily be the best interest of
the actual company when in reality they
can still get what they want without
acquiring them you see what I'm saying
think too
is at the end of the day we really got
to see what they do with Bethesda before
I want them to buy another publisher
like yeah it's like right now they got
so much on their plate do we really want
Microsoft to double down again and then
like at that point are they going to be
able are they going to be able to manage
all that like this is the thing like
people's assumption that they're sort of
spreading themselves out too thin right
and they they they that's why they're
keeping so much Bethesda so Bethesda
they don't have to do all this stuff
Bethesda does like they kept the
publishing arm because at the end of the
day they don't want to have to you know
put all of their responsibilities on
Microsoft's PR so they have their own PR
department that goes through Microsoft
PR at the end of the day like I said It
reminds me like I said Forte knows what
I'm talking about in terms of the bungee
dude do I want Microsoft to acquire
bungee yes but at the end of the day if
they're able to get Beyond light all
their IP all the stuff that matters
which is Destiny right you know what I'm
saying then you still accomplishing the
same goal there still have Yakuza in
Game Pass exclusive you know whether it
be six months to a year whatever it is
and that's a huge deal right so to me
it's like it's like you know you ain't
got a trick on it you know what I'm
saying like you ain't got a trick on the
chicken you know what I'm saying like
you know where I'm going you know what
I'm saying like and and that's the thing
with Sega Sega maybe doesn't have the
same leg to stand on that a Bethesda had
to stand on like if if if you come out
it might have been a different
conversation if Microsoft goes to Todd
how with and it's like we want Starfield
for a year exclusive and Todd Howard
looks at them and says it doesn't nah
that doesn't work for us like we we
might give you some extra like maybe
some DLC or something like that but it
doesn't work for us if we know we're GNA
make all this money across all the
platforms right so Sega doesn't have
that Leverage necessar What I saying
that's what I think I I I honestly think
sometimes as fans sometimes we overrate
a little bit of that that value but
anyway real quick um shout out to Kurt
and JD gamer they said we missed some
super chat so let's just double check
back with the super chats we definitely
want to get those no we have right at
the end we have JD okay said two he said
we got two super chats from JD he said
hold on let me check let me check just
keep talking I'll go yeah oh yeah I do
see Kurt I do see it let me get oh okay
yeah I have uh we got Kurt with the $5
Super Chat thanks for the show the show
today guys 2020 is crazy we woke up to
an earthquake in Massachusetts in
Massachusetts oh my god wow hly this
year is crazy absolutely that you're not
there if you are
did we get this one from JD gamer
Microsoft obviously not buying seg or
they wouldn't have been brok and selling
off parts of the company so Capcom it is
maybe from softer yeah I'm with all that
I'm with all that you know you I I do
think you went straight to stitch I do
think you accidentally missra I miss I
missed that's because you was looking at
that St yeah he was ready for he ready
for smoke he's popping off he's ready to
pop off of Stitch that's all that
was so who so who's to say that this
couldn't be a big deal like the Bethesda
deal but in a different way um let's say
we already know that Microsoft is
willing to make out of pocket deals with
other companies they did it with
GameStop through profit sharing who's
not to say that they can get into a
profit sharing deal with Sega where Sega
is literally the face of Xbox and Japan
and every and every if and everything
that is sold through Japan is funed
through Sega there and Sega is is
basically the Forefront of
consoles and selling games and the games
they make that bring people into that
ecosystem through Xbox and Japan you
know be crazy if like second the Xbox
brand like merged yeah listen ain't too
far out the road they don't have to buy
them to do that they can literally just
use them as a funel as the face of Xbox
and Japan exactly exactly sometimes
Partnerships and those deals of those
nature are actually more beneficial than
actually the straight up acquisition but
yeah man that's what I got we are going
to move on if we all caught up and the
final one I believe this is youa we had
a good one man what's going on some
retrospective talk yeah man so again we
are days away from the start of the
ninth generation of consoles right and
the eighth generation has been
interesting to say the least right so uh
I know a couple of shows back we talked
about like our top games of of the
generation so now I just want to talk
about what you guys remember about this
gen that sort of formulated everything
that happened like highs for both
consoles lows for both consoles events
that they sort of change the way we
think about games things big special
things that happened during the course
of this generation that we can look back
on as touchstones uh of how things have
changed and how you know what we look
like moving into the ninth generation uh
starting next week so before that let me
get this uh perfect Shogun with the $10
Super Chat as we stand at the dawn of a
new generation no matter which side
you're on May your resolutions be high
your frame rate be locked your batteries
be charged and that like button be
smashed salute salute to the
show Fant and he joined I think you
joined the real earli or upgraded the
realm earlier so put the horns in there
for Shun yeah put the horns in there for
Shogun man salute to that brother man
salute no doubt so let let me give you
guys like a little framing of kind of
what what happened and so shout out to
uh fiction talk uh they because I was
looking online like I need something to
kind of break everything down for me
because obviously you don't remember
everything right so
so let's start from the beginning right
we have the Xbox One reveal disaster as
they right so again I don't want to I
don't want to go through each point
right I I got some ready I got some
ready what you feel so so we have you
know we start with the Xbox One real
disaster PlayStation fire shots back
obviously the way they do they show us
how to share games um obviously the Wii
the Wii U sort of crashed and burned uh
the connect the connect gets uh
assassinated and and
and then we get into things like it's
kind of crazy to think that the the Wii
U was this
generation is gonna dominate this one
switch is technal already got a 70
million point
lead coming in hot coming in hot then we
got you know the infamous loot boxes
that we all know and love right B
Battlefront um then we got the
announcement of bat compat on the Xbox
One from from Microsoft which was huge
and it kind of kind of began the Turning
Point the Turning of the ship for the
Xbox brand uh with with positive talk
right then obviously we got to talk
about Battle Royale Battle
Royale you give away too much man
takeing my all right so I'm G let y' go
I'm you guys decide who goes first I'm
gonna let y'all go then we let me jump
over let me jump this I have some stuff
right he don't want nobody to take all
taking my balls I'm like Dam this is
good stuff look we got high point low
points defining moments retrospective AP
gen all right so for me high points Sony
transforms the game from The Cinematic
over the shoulder my hashtag just one
narrative they dominate with that format
with the God of War you know what I'm
saying Spidey Last of Us ghost they
completely change that and it it just
really mind bro what they doing so that
that's one for me there a second one for
me is a hot point like you said the
complete um
Underdog Story The Comeback of Nintendo
right after the Wii U and then you're
like they dead in the water there's no
way they're finished like and then the
switch gets announced you're like okay
maybe and adct you already know like I
remember you was like yo we got to
launch with Zelda if you don't nor Zelda
I'm telling you Cog it's going to be a
fail it's an arrow and I was like all
right all right and then we saw that
trailer attic what was them Fields Don't
Front the F crazy son he was like you
know he was clowning up the M it was the
ultimate comeback story there for a
while I was watching the Zelda trailer
on retweet bro on retweet the music hit
and we like oh they open world they
doing you know what I'm saying all right
cool this is a launch game so salute to
them um my low I'm G give two low points
power mattering and then it
doesn't y'all know where I'm going you
know what I'm saying like yo 1080p makes
you better you know what I'm saying like
yo saiding you're 9900 you looking
spooky out here then you know we got
that and and and and and how you know
once things the mid Generation stuff and
that kind of change and it's the 4K and
who's checkerboard and all that so all
that was crazy right another thing was
we got like like you s said I mean Xbox
start Xbox One start of the
Gen W boy you know this is how you trade
games that was that was like ether that
was ether and um connect resources
taking up a little bit too much and as
far as that and then the lack of the
first party right so we all know the the
story how they stumbling out the gate
and the third I give actually third will
um like you said you going take too much
Battle Royale man look shout out to pubg
shout out to fortnite for stealing the
pubg for to making it better but then
everybody in their moms want a Mumble
rap with that damn Battle Royal
everybody got a song everybody got a
battle R law Breakers and this one and
that one and I'm just law Breakers
wasn't a battle Royale was it one of
them what did he have a battle
Ro it was over overwat type of yeah but
it had it was another was he he he was
making a what you call oh he tried after
he somethings wasn't it yeah some the
one with the bikes with with the bikes
and the joint and then everybody we he
made it like six months or something
like that yeah everybody yeah Ral shout
out to Li FL yeah like everybody had a
battle royale track yo I got one I got
one you know what I'm saying so that was
that um defining moments I would say I'm
GNA get a lot of flack for this um when
the gaming industry lost their mind gave
OverWatch the game of the year I was
tight I saw that coming I was tight I
was living I was like that's what we
doing gaming industry okay and but
another one though I will say is um even
though it was in Microsoft Getting It
Right game awards series x hellblade 2
and the in the roof just blowing off the
doors like yo this is crazy you know I'm
saying so it's it's a it's a fun g a lot
of ups and downs but those are the kind
of stuff that um kind of stand out for
me you know what I'm saying for this for
this generation what about you Forte get
you get back in the move then we get it
to so yeah so if I you got to start with
the good stuff man let's get it let's
get it start with the good stuff the
good stuff has been just the fact that
it's been a It's been a gener
of just having playing with a bunch of
different friends man like I I met more
I thought I met more people during the
360 generation than anything has nothing
it's not even comparable to this
Generations facts and that's mostly due
to the games that we got the games that
we got were more Community focused you
know everything from all of the like
starting with Borderlands and going
through um destiny and going through
even division as much as we give it a
bunch of slander on the Channel every
once in a while all of those games um
it's like the complete portal opposite
of like you said how Battle Royale is
Battle Royale is probably the signature
um genre that like evolved throughout
this generation but just the evolution
of community type games looter Shooters
and stuff like that that's like
literally the thing that I felt like
defined a generation like probably not
as much as like you said Battle Royale
but the next best thing just I love that
the most because that's the thing I like
to just like dive into the most but when
it comes to like you know the best the
worst thing Halo not
being Halo not being a thing this
generation yeah you're right about the
whole generation right yeah the whole
generation it's like Mass Effect is my
Mass Effect is my favorite franchise
because Halo literally dropped the ball
so much this generation yeah it's like
because Halo was my favorite franchise
of all time but then I have to step that
so far back because everything about
Mass Effect even with a lackluster
Andromeda I still feel like is had a
better showing to what we got for Halo
this generation and I just feel that's
just so disappointing to me to know that
we came into this generation with five
Studios or six Studios one left now
we're leaving with 23 so we're in a good
place but no going throughout the whole
part of the beginning of this year they
just didn't do that game any justice
Hurts the Most no doubt no doubt what
Hur the most but if I had to go to the
if I had to go to the complete opposite
side of that I really don't think Sony
had any misses I think if you want to
say the beginning of the generation was
a Miss because they didn't have a lot of
really impactful games there you could
probably have a case but some people
will tell you that games like Kill Zone
and stuff like that they actually did
enjoy but man God of War my game of the
generation God of War I was one of those
people like yo why Kratos can't jump y
remember yeah remember that was a big
controversy when we I was like one like
yo he can't jump what is this it wasn't
the fact that he couldn't jump it was
the fact that all of his previous games
was him jumping like regardless if it
was him jumping to another and you know
clearly you saw the the fact that they
took that feature and that function out
of the game you saw it because the boss
fights were not what they used to be
exactly so for me seeing the Evol and
this is why and I think this is when it
kind of transformed for me because that
was like right before like right in the
middle of the generation where I was
like really into this whole community
that we're in now where I was like you
know what you just got to pause just
because it may not be something you
don't like you don't know what it's
going to be like until that game comes
out and let me tell you I ain't even
realized I couldn't jump in that game
when I started playing because it wasn't
a focused part of the game so just the
evolution of gam play especially on the
Sony side has probably been the the one
thing that stands out the most to me
that's what stands out the most and I
think that's why you see so many people
getting on the other side getting on
Team Green because we're not asking well
we haven't been asking for that and I
think that's what we want to see
Microsoft get to in the
# just one they kill me yo when I say
hash just one they kill me we don't need
a title like we don't need a copy format
I'm like bro that formula all I'm asking
is just make one game in that formula
you got all those Studios bro but that
that over the shoulder cinematic dope
storytelling action that joint work all
I'm saying you got 23 Studios you can
give me one of them joints yeah so I
think that's where I think that's where
we're going to be heading to but uh
overall My Crown Dr has to go to
Nintendo like Nintendo talk about
they I was in love with Horizon D zero
Dawn even knowing the story was Bland as
hell I was into the whole storyline with
the trck it was like trck with on
steroids that's what that game felt like
I was willing to push through then
breath of the wild dropped out and and
it reminded me about what what I I was
like oh this is what a open world game
should be it reminded me of what it's
like oh yo
this is what it should be and then yes
they have had a whole they had a whole
bunch of droughts in between um now and
then with a bunch of different games but
the one thing that will not be denied is
the fact that they know what they're
they know who their players are facts
and they support their players and their
players support them my most memorable
moment came when I was in my store
working it was during the VGA I was at
work Smash Brothers was releasing that
day cuz it that was the year that smash
couldn't be nominated cuz it was
releasing on the same day as the VGA yo
Stitch put you time for Mad switch
talking you like whatever switches that
switches that deal I had I had a hundred
people in my store and when they
announced the DLC for U Smash Brothers
and Joker for Persona was the DLC
character my store erupted and it was
literally the best like listen the best
single moment thing ever experienced in
a gaming and gaming seeing that many
people happy to see something so little
be celebrated that hard so that that
stands out the most because like I said
the community to me is the biggest thing
and seeing that in first place is What
mattered the most no doubt y the chat is
so Stitch got so many time
time every time Forte say switch
anything time move
onbody a switch Stitch exactly you know
what I'm saying No Doubt let's get the
um let's get adct man what what you got
man like highs the lows the defining
moments for you this is adct let's get
I'll start with the
lows I think probably the the one of the
most lows I've been in this whole
generation is when Fallout 4 came out
cuz wow I remember I played that game I
was so disappointed I I was playing that
game with disgust I remember I was in a
party with John and I was like I the
more I talk to John about stuff I didn't
like about the game I was getting more
and more pissed I was like because he
started bringing stuff up and I'm like
you're right you're right you're right
I'm like but that's the man like they
started to strip stuff away from
you it was it like I've always said
Fallout is a good shooter it is a bad
Fallout game um another big part I was
disappointed with I know a lot of people
ain't gonna agree with this is is when I
play breath of the wild like oh yeah I
know I you know I'm a huge Zelda fan
I've played them all multiple times I've
beat them all multiple times and uh
Zelda it's like I said great game that
came out that year bad Zelda game yeah
because you won dungeons you're the
dungeon guy yeah well that's literally
what Zelda is about is dungeons ad
continue it's not attic swirl every you
know we I'm trying to start trouble you
you damn damn you didn't fall for it
damn all right probably my highlights I
don't think there was a time even this
generation last generation and going to
the future I don't think there's going
to be a time to ever beat Microsoft B
Bethesda
like I was
literally mind blown like I was
speechless like I would never forget my
mom was like I said I've said the story
before my mom was literally behind me uh
because she uh she came over from her
boyfriend's as she stay I I remember
seeing it and I had my hands like this
like I I was I was like oh my God oh my
God my mom's like what what's WR like
yeah we were like where it was like
where was you I was asleep was that's a
good point it it's just like that that
is such probably the most memorable
thing I've ever seen um you know I was
kind of disappointed with the State of
Decay launch I'm not could lie with that
I actually probably one of the biggest
highlights is when I play God of War the
original God of Wars get a lot of votes
yeah I really enjoyed that game because
of how much but I have to put above them
all when I played ghost of
shishima got that got that how you put
that I forgot about that continue
because of the last boss like I'm a boss
fight and like when I love when they put
one-on-one fights and they make it
greatest Duss in the business and when
you fought uh what was that dude the
last boss's name we spoil too much don't
SPO don't SPO that don't that no no the
main character you mean Jin Sakai Jin
Sakai the the no the dude
thater cut this man this
man no but
easy moving
along look man you guys look you guys G
but I'm gonna undo my I'm gonna take no
you good you good you
good like I was just saying that like I
really enjoyed like the one-on-one
fights and when they the way that ghost
shishima put that off and you know
what's funny is by the time the rap came
out I already got R of my PlayStation
yeah and I was like man here looking at
this and I'm like I never wanted to play
a concept more than I wanted to play
that damn game and I'm sitting here like
I'm it was so lit that I'm considering
do I really need this X on day one no
fact and I will give you credit because
I I will say this like you're my
barometer when it comes to if people are
frauding on hype or not so I like add
what's up beat it because I I I don't I
don't touch base with you until you beat
the game cuz sometimes you either be
very high on it in the beginning or very
low on it and then as it goes on you
either you know change based on the game
quality and I know a big thing for you
was ending and you would I remember I
hit you you was like yo I felt away like
it it there's very few games to get me
emotional very few games like life is
strange is one of them there's very few
games and by the end of that game I was
I don't can I just turn it off can I is
that an option y it's one of them type
of situation so to hear you do that was
super lit but yeah I I I agree I forgot
about yeah go let's get the super chat
then uh uh solve you finish up your
jointed let me just say one more game
like Final Fantasy 15 like I I remember
you got remember how hyp I was that game
that game came out man I played it I and
then there was that the one of the
chapters chapter 11 was so bad
that Enix went back and redid
it it was so drug out that I'm sitting
here playing this game I'm talking to
John while I'm playing it I'm like don't
even know what I'm doing anymore like I
I I'm literally so bad I'm listening to
podcast and not listening to the game
yeah and I do that with Destiny when I
do stuff that that you could take your
brain out of the situation and honor
honorable mention before we get to Super
chats Final Fantasy 7 remake in I was
about to say
mention because we ain't going to spoil
what we do but that that we needed to do
some podcast for some therapeutic stuff
for that but anyway you know what you
know the S like this one probably one of
the lowest this
industry the amount of capping that
these men would do for Red Dead te oh my
God I remember I played this game I was
oh it looks good I was like but where's
that game play at though
trying to compare you like oh the
shooting is not on par with
Destiny tell me how Red Dead ain't
changed his gameplay in 15 years tell me
how that
happen they actually made it less game
gamey than the first one like to be to
be believed that's what they did it's
it's it's a it's a simulator it's not
it's l of a game not a capping for that
game is unrealistic I feel like people
that cap for that game they need mental
help oh my God my beef with people's
beef with the game is that you were
trying to ascribe things to it that it
just never been there like you comparing
it to like like these third person
shooters with
like oh my God yo get this super chat
then I'll let you finish off your topic
um let me see we have smoo SM uh 246
with the $5 Super Chat putting in
overtime this weekend so I can enjoy
release day thank you for giving me
great content to get me through salute
that we have the living flame with the
$2 Super Chat PlayStation indeed had no
misses like the puddles yeah
puddles man when Spiderman was coming
out and the puddlegate stuff happened I
remember I made a thumbnail for kid
smooth about the puddlegate man like it
was literally Point like this with
puddles at the top yeah I remember that
sh sh think Kofi was in a mix of that
too sh oh my god wow kofy was doing so
much with puddlegate people were
reporting on his channel like
then we have next up we have Michael
aew the with the $5 Super Chat yo I love
God of War but a fan of the old style
Xbox needs to remaster Dante's Inferno
that game on backup Pat on 1X is the
truth yeah I forgot about Dante's
Inferno yes sir then we have JD gabber
with the $10 chat we've given Sony too
much credit and not enough to Microsoft
we do it too much can't have that Halo 5
multiplayer was at his best ever Quantum
break was underrated uh GT was a money
grab and Forza is king or he was
Microsoft's best new IP and I want rise
too in his defense we don't give Forza
enough credit as the definitive in my
opinion yeah we should especially
Horizon as we shouldn't as we shouldn't
oh my God
Jesus world we don't recognize Racers at
all oh my God God not GNA recognize one
whole you
like because the shooting is not as good
as
destiny
that's why you don't like Racers cuz it
Doesn't shoot like Destiny too like
Racers and you come into the attic realm
you get booted you don't come in yo
shout out to my European Brothers for
for helping the Xbox generation with
your continued support of the fero spa
series
continue then we have Stitch with the $2
Super Chat you're hyping up cardboard
stop it Stitch beh ha that nobody
mentioned Lao nobody said nobody said
nothing about Lao he be then we got
Victor Allis with $5 Super Chat great
show and salute to King get well sir I
would like Sega in Xbox's hands just to
see a Sonic ory like game to be crazy
that' be fine 12 HZ oh they could what
they could blast process 120 Herz for
Sonic yeah that be fine what else we got
all right I think we just jumped in the
living flame with the $2 Super Chat just
started playing Horizon 4 godamn it's
good tell adct please he needs to know
already booted like you're reading this
from the
bushes bushes
damn put a cherry on your topic man what
you yeah man like for me obviously I
start with the bad and the bad was was
really bad there was no chance in hell
in my mind and this is where I came up
with the theory about uh uh these these
two companies being in cahoots to just
one of them shines one one generation
and the other one doesn't because I was
just
like you you st stepped on the rake in a
way that you could not imagine coming
out of the 360
generation they really did TV TVV and it
was just like it was just so toned deaf
and everything about it just felt
completely wrong and it was just like I
I just it was it was scary man I was
like what the hell but and then at the
end of the day just the narrative in the
beginning undid them for the entire
generation basically so many by the time
the consoles launched right all the
connect stuff was kind of out the window
yes the connect was still sucking power
from it but when you look at the launch
line yeah when you look at the launch
lineup I thought Xbox's launch line that
launch lineup was far superior yeahor at
that at that point you look at it and
it's like the narrative really continued
to carry it um forward and I was like
damn oh this is what happens when you
when you stumble early on often times
that is just enough to get enough and if
you think about it you know this is the
first time they ever made a a real run
at Sony like they made the real run in
the 360 generation and then they they
kind of like crapped it all away um so
that was tough to see just because it
was just mised up after M up after
mistep um so that's that um then after
that one of the things that bothered me
was kind of like the loot box stuff
because I was like okay all of these
games of the service are be becoming
this this this huge thing right and you
know I give Destiny a lot of crap but
Destiny did it the right way giving you
a $60 game and we're gonna keep giving
you stuff like you're gonna have to pay
for it but it's going to be worth it and
it matters and we're not going to nickel
and dime you if you want to spend money
it's here right um and to me all these
other games try to figure out ways to
just get your money and and kind of you
know what I'm call it shout out to the
to the fall of the destiny killers in
this generation all these fraud games
let's get them for tap all these 14
every time the new game come out it's
over Anthem is here division two is here
yeah Borderlands all these games right
we got it here for months it's all for
you guys and what ends up happening what
ends up Happ tell them Forte adct is
right every time hey man I've been
telling I've been telling people for
years that it ain't gonna be a game
that's gonna take Destiny down it's
going to be Destiny itself yeah
it's when will they learn that's it's at
that point now and the people don't
realize it by now we're going this game
has made it through an entire generation
it's going to be starting off a
completely another generation so it's a
staple they ain't going anywhere they
got to bend the knee brother they just
got to bend the knee that's why it's so
big of Sol to say to continue Sol I
gotta say that I gotta say that it's not
the game that I want from Bungie but I
get it I get it um but so so those are
to me were sort of the low points and
and and and to see that sort of change
moving forward as we move into this next
next generation for me the Microsoft
turnaround was huge and to me it started
with the back compat announcement back
compat announcement felt like I would
say that's when they started their turn
around it really does because it's like
okay it's telling you look we have a
plan in place it's G to take us a while
to get there and you're gonna be mad
with us because you're not going to see
it immediately but here are the
breadcrumbs to it um and then obviously
that leading into Game Pass and and this
entire new way of thinking about how do
we consume games and doing it in a way
that they needed to do which is to be
the most consumer friendly product out
there they absolutely went completely
opposite of Sony um in that regard and
and to see them change and for it to
work for them right because it could
have blown up in their face and people
like nah we're not about this and and so
far it hasn't and so I'm excited to see
the fact that going into this new
generation both of these consoles are
strong yeah and then now on the Sony
side I gotta agree with Forte man they
in the beginning they started slow and I
felt a lot of the love they got was
unwarranted it was like it was just it
seemed like it was more hate for
Microsoft than love for Sony yeah yeah
but they double down and when you start
seeing these you know they double down
on what they're good at narrative third
person based
games and they just really they they
they sort of spit shine yeah they they
just presentation I remember being
at we came off one of those it was me
you we all at the the house we came off
of Microsoft's press conference and we
we weren't too happy we got we got to
attack for that at the time I remember
that was I was going to put that as one
of my Lads like I don't think terms of
Microsoft I've ever been that low with
them bro and then we go back to the crib
and Cali I the compound of Castle and we
watched this Sony press conference right
and is even the presentation of the
games like damn yo you see that God War
you like damn yo this joint is crazy son
and we like yo we just need Microsoft to
make these type of games man like it was
just like I felt you on it's something
about like I said we always said if it's
the the the movie background or whatever
it is even the presentation just the way
they just get into the game it's no
fluff it's no here it is let's go and
the thing about it is besides the
obviously having the movie background
it's just the fact that it felt like at
throughout the entire generation they
really listen to their base right and
and they listen to what their base gets
excited over and they just kept giving
them that they're like oh if our base
because our base is loud if we keep
giving them what they want the the
message is gonna continue to propagate
it's just gonna happen and they just
kept doing it one game after the other
one game after they had their missteps
like you know in the beginning days gone
wasn't the greatest thing in the world
um you know some of them didn't
necessarily hit right but they just kept
doing it and when you talk about like
the things that naughty dog has done in
terms of narrative storytelling and I'm
this is this might be an unpopular
opinion but when it compare I'm not
necessarily super convinced with Sony's
open worlds right yeah I got I got a
yeah I found after a while that Horizon
zero DA's open world got a little same
for Ghost of sushima for me in terms of
the open worldness of it I I think I
think they're very good I love their I
love their linear wide games right Last
of Us your God of War
but it seems like they still got to
figure out the open worlds and how to
populate those open worlds with super
interesting stuff and they get to
continue to work on that okay but to me
uh you can't undermine what Sony's done
this year and I think if King was here
he'd say it too like you know all jokes
aside he's like yo they kind of no he
gave it up the last remember that
podcast we had him last of us too he
blew us away we were like what like he
gave it up the
time I'm just in conclusion I'm super
excited for what's to come I think both
of these companies have figured out
their Lanes in a way that we haven't
seen before and I think they both gonna
be heading on all cylinders moving
forward I I really do I'm super excited
for what's to come I really am I agree
and I think next gen the competition is
gonna be fierce you know we got these
two powerful consoles Microsoft's
gearing up you already know Sony's
taking them very seriously to it's going
to be a battle man but that's what we
got so we GNA move we got super chat
before I get into the poll and get up
out of here yeah we do actually we have
let me
see Mass Effect Dan Rodriguez the $5
Super Chat Dan I'm not feeling it read
say say it with your chest s read it
with your chest Mass Effect two is is
that greater than I don't know that I
don't
know greater
lesbi 2 is greater than m
one official season
gaming a what's going on man you have
your underling
over here doing too much Lord Lord Dan
Rodriguez if you are under dur rest we
can request a trade for you to come over
to the IR La you know what I'm saying
like we could request we can put that in
cuz you are under duress by Your Leader
over there am I being shipped out there
hey we we we we like that Rodriguez
man swap Latino we got the
Latino No Doubt we got s with the $5
Super Chat King I thought you're not
here but I know you listen uh no one
here today talking about that spooky PS5
SSD and lack of external storage support
for the PS5 yeah we we kept the smoke
out of the talk today we trust me I miss
that he's here cuz I know king would
have went in on that oh my God his
moments these are his moments I know he
would have asked Jason ronal he would
asked Jason super messy that's what
that's the part I miss cuz he don't play
remember we had B pis Cella on and he
was like is it possible that so they
could be fudging the numbers I was like
K what is going on with you this is NPD
like he does not shoot to the yo send K
some love man get till he gets better
man he heals up because you know how do
what else we got uh so JD G with the $5
Super Chat to be clear Gran Turismo is
Sony's largest franchise not God of War
racing is not Niche it's a huge thank
you thank
you it's a huge genre that has existed
since the beginning and will be here
after after BR
after what talking about he talking
about how you don't know what you're
talking about with
racing see I don't even hear the word
racing so I didn't see
it about that technical style that's
what it is game a master or racing games
I thought you were a difficult
game living flame put some respect he
gonna put respect on playground name
when it get Fable they need GNA know who
they
are racing guy look at you guys
I bet you the be
hot go straight in the bushes with
it when they make Fable acting like
Fable is a racing game get out here that
but you're gonna know who playground is
magically yeah it's gonna be G be very
races be C for playground watch the only
time a racing game is acceptable is if I
can throw green shells at you that's
all I can throw Savage we caught up to
oh we got we got Smitty Smith with the
$2 to chat destiny and still heavyweight
champion of the
world that's right heard that
dizzy I think we're caught up no no no
we got a super chat from JD gamer F Sony
drop Banger after Banger true Sony
dropped five big a triaa first party
triaa bangers over seven years with 23
Studios Microsoft will out shine Sony
soon actually you know I don't
completely agree h what you said but I
have always stated that if Sony don't
start buying some studios Microsoft's
gonna outpace him I have they but I
think Sony Sony's not really they'll buy
some some other Studios but they've been
bolstering their Studios so when when
you talk when you see these these
release dates I don't know that they
we're that far off like when they say
2021 God of War it could be like because
they bolstering their teams to to get
these games out are they going to
release that all their games in one year
though that's the thing that's a lot
of you're not giving God of War and
Horizon enough time to breathe that's
why I just don't think I mean it could
Poss let's be real here Sony came
together in that little room discussing
what that conference was going to be
it's like yo this is this looking spooky
but tell me if they bolstered their
teams to the point if they bolster their
teams to the point where they could give
you one of those every three years
instead of every five they they went
they talked in the back and they say yo
when's God war going be we're like 2022
maybe was like oh 2022 let's say it's
coming out next year we got it we just
say we delayed it yo s we need you to
read slowo chat continue no I don't need
to read that you need to read this you
Ain gonna read that you
refuse I gota see this let's get this
actually U let Forte read it from his
DPS brother for read for his DPS brother
out here all right shout out to slowo
backslap with the5 Super Chat thanks for
the support brother anyone who thinks
Mass Effect one is greater than Mass
Effect 2 picks their nose and East
boogers they also hold a controller with
their feet since they think the make a
control shout out to my
boy slow so ites really surprise the
worst part this is the worst part of
Mass Effect one was the make off oh
thank thank you you can literally be
riding on a planet and hit a pebble in
the
sh y shout out to Iron Mike in the chat
it's not in color I'm read it
anyway Mass Effect 2 was made for filthy
casual look we moving on we moving on we
moving on get messy that podcast is
coming that terrible this is terrible we
are we officially caught up so we get
this PO about yes sir all right no doubt
man chat super messy today salute you
already know so look with both the
series X and S consoles now approaching
what game excites you the most to play
on the new hardware your choices are a
Yakuza like a dragon B Valhalla
mickala C gears tactics D bright memory
1.0 or E I don't care y'all C yall still
playing backpack games out
front those are the choices please Rock
the vot when it goes up today later on
today yo salute to the realm and salute
to Lord Jason Ronald that pulled up
project manager of Team Xbox creator of
the series X and the series s he was
absolutely amazing cannot thank him
enough and Microsoft enough for pulling
up man it was a tremendous tremendous
show good to see the support by
everybody in the realm so let's do these
outros right quick gaming Forte our
brother man thank you for pulling up in
the realm on last minute Duty where can
to find people find you what you got
going on Sir yo man first of all you
guys do an amazing job I'm super proud
to see you guys grow and get the um get
the viewership and success with all the
people that's coming on the show it's
it's like literally legitimized you guys
didn't need it but I know how it how
people feel when it comes to like the
growth of your channels and your
platform in general and this literally
is just helping you guys blow up more so
I'm just happy to see you guys do it
thank but um outside of that man gaming
Forte Everywhere YouTube Twitter Xbox
Live uh check me out on DPS podcast it's
on Thursday nights 900 PM me my boy
slowmo backslab um let's get him to a th
Subs he's like just over 700 if he does
he has to play Buck snacks and he will
stream it for all of us and if he gets
to 2,000 Subs which it will be a stretch
goal he has to get the platinum in the
game yes which would be which would be
incredible because that dude doesn't
understand how great his streams are
when he does play his game that he
doesn't want to play but uh yeah other
than that it's um brat podcast every
Wednesday night 900m check us out over
there with B Money Eric Jackson um B
Money Eric um arque I can't forget him
he's the host show the host can't forget
the host and um check out the last
episode because our boy the the ninja
unlocked was on the show last week so
check him out on the show if you missed
it it was a great time and um as always
man you have a great weekend let's get
to some football no doubt you already
know salute Forte pulling up DPS you
already know Brad podcast you already
know everybody in the real and yes
slowmo that is not lies they want you to
platinum and play games that you don't
like we love it we love your misery
brother thank
you Lord adct man coming in with the
smoke as usual young wolf what's up man
where can they find any new hot more
videos coming you can find me on Twitter
I'm not gonna say it the correct way
because King's out here I got to respect
the king you can follow me on Twitter at
Lord
ad I definitely go check out you know uh
Forte's podcast DPS it's a very
interesting podcast I still need to pull
up on there eventually I've just been
busy that day how you always interesting
if you never pulled
up you about pull like as a guest oh my
godt
early hey it's it's not it's not it's
I'm not part of DPS if it's not a part
of slander come on now oh speaking of
which I might as well announce it now um
your boy Cognito will be on DPS podcast
this Thursday so please jump through you
got room for two yeah what's up pull up
you know what you know yeah let's do
yeah yeah yeah yeah you want you want to
come through bro you can come through
yeah yeah I'll come up there
collaboration yeah we G yo we we G to
ruin PlayStation's day because you know
we don't really care about PlayStation
it's all about Xbox that day look look
Pi even we all going to have
PlayStations I'm picking mine up on
Thursday so I'll be in progress join
that's
right that's what's all right so um
definitely you know looking for the
first thing I want to say is you know
Lord Ronald we it is a an honor of
someone that you know he had no business
being on this show obviously we're a lot
bigger than we used to be but still that
man's uh time is very valuable in the
fact that he you know what shout out to
for with
random the fact that he took the time to
come on the show on a Sunday at like
eight o'clock in the morning his time
it's very humbling you know we're gonna
do whatever we can to keep pushing the
podcast forward I do want to have an
announcement real quick uh you know we
are go the last show of the year will be
the uh the 20th uh we won't be doing a
show on the 27th and that's going to be
a community p uh podcast we're gonna you
know go over all the highlights of the
entire generation kind of like this last
topic but a little bit more extended so
definitely be looking out for more
information on that because I'm going to
be looking into bring any more guests on
during that time it's going to be a
celebration to the entire generation for
all of gaming and you know I want to
appreciate everyone came in we had like
almost 800 people at one time wow uh you
know it's definitely I love seeing the
podcast grow as much as we can uh you
know definitely if you still here man
you are the VIPs you are the goat you're
still in here at outros definitely hit
that like button if you guys haven't hit
it now we'll see you next week we're
going to be doing uh me and calledo
still haven't come together we're g to
figure out exactly that we were run want
to run next week obviously next week is
the launch of the consoles they both
will be out by then so we're going to
try to do as much as we can to uh have a
good show for you guys next week you
know we will see about getting an Xbox
and a PlayStation D depending on what
happens between here and there but
definitely look out for that we're going
to be doing a lot next week uh
definitely be here both conserts will be
out and we'll have a lot to say shout
out to Kendrick star Mass Effect 2 has
the elusive man end of story I feel you
um you want to get that super chat uh
sir we got two super chats we have E
Murray with the $5 Super Chat Sony has
lost devs to Xbox team so where they
bolstering Studios you can't really say
they're losing devs like when it comes
to that Santa Monica area these guys are
you know these de devs jump from bed to
bed dude that's like like that's what
they do so
it's yeah they're not they're not really
being poached like that
next they leave their B buzz in their
own bed and don't bring them here
exactly exactly then we have the wise G
with $2 Super Chat I want to thank you
guys for the well wishes no doubt no
doubt brother it's good to see your
tweets when we saw that we were so happy
man we're glad you're doing better
brother for sure so in addition to that
like I said before guys show some love
to obviously the wiso gamer and of
course the Nintendo Guru yes um our
brothers they need our help they need
our support so make sure we send them
well wishes um so for me you know where
you can find me you can find me L sa up
here on Twitter you know that you know
that I will be doing I will be waiting
patiently and I may have to camp out in
front of a GameStop to get my Xbox on
time
so we got do do what we got we need to
get you another outro man yeah for you
for sure so oh for we I like them song I
I I was looking forward to the outro
last week and I was like oh man it ain't
gonna be no more outros because they
already gave away the system hold no no
we be utilizing song we we we like the
uh that the SS tender we we need
serenation to continue yes and the music
and the music brother I next some
but got need some more fire let's do it
let's do it let's do it so one one thing
I just want to say to the entire Gaming
Community and to Twitter guys I know
there's been a lot of vitory over the
past couple of weeks and it as the
consoles come out get it gets closer to
launch people get like more and more in
their feelings like this week this past
week on Twitter has been quite frankly
kind of disgusting but you know it's
hard for the course but you know what
the time is here the consoles are out in
a couple of days why not just why don't
we make an effort to just shut up and
game everybody just shut up and play
facts
like happen no my thing is how about
people just put up some Twitter pictures
of games they playing and who they
playing with like was is it it's like a
lost art now like it gets it gets so it
gets so caught up in the BS about this
one's better this you know that stuff is
out the window do spend all day on
Twitter beefing instead of playing games
like there's no no one's having fun no
one's enjoying themselves no one's like
yo I just played such such I just beat
this I had a great time nah your conso
whack my
conso show me show me you that you're
playing I would love to have more time
to play games and then people that have
the time spend it on Twitter like I no
man and chats and on Twitter all day
beefing you clearly ain't playing no
games fam yeah man let's go like I said
let's shut up and play shut up and play
I'm with that I'm with that you know
what I'm saying yeah so that's that and
listen man L here listen truly humbled
from y'all man the support was amazing
again shout out to Jason R man what an
interview truly humble and again the
growth and the support it's all because
of you guys man like you guys ask these
guys to come on and and it's without you
and the support and retweeting and the
likes and even from our PE Forte all you
guys man from day one yall know what it
is with us we you know still the same
old lords even when we had 10 15 people
in the chat and yall Still rocking with
us strong so salute we got more special
things cooking and it was a fun show man
so that's all I got and you guys better
uh you know our personal friends need to
thank you guys because since you guys
come in such Dr uh some Crow such crowds
we're not on them all the time for not
being in the chat facts exactly we ain't
got to beat up our friends and be like
why you wasn't in the chat this week CUA
y
came listen that's all I got Yo
everybody enjoy this Sunday let's get to
this football we out we will see y next
week week launch week y'all play them
games stop beefing put put some pictures
up of games being played that's what I
want to see all right
[Music]
peace